three
two
[Music]
hello hello
it is august hello
a beautiful
summer friday
[Applause]
i don't know where you guys live but
it's getting hot
over here
you know
it felt like kind of a temperate summer
and then all of a sudden it got hot
so i hope you're keeping cool wherever
you are ela i know you're keeping cool
check out that fit and go hard as heck
thank you show those off those deep
wells
is that what you call it when this fat
corduroys
it's like a large
large whale a whale
where like w-a-l-e
it's called a whale
not a whale like the animal i know but
it's pronounced whale
[Music]
uh yes corridor yeah oh [ __ ] that's so
crazy to me it's a [ __ ] whale show
off your whales
yo those are fat whales dude i was just
telling ethan before we started this has
like
such a cool feature that um
adjustable for thanksgiving
or what i like to call dinner ladies and
gentlemen
yeah
yeah fantastic
and do you find that as someone as
slender as yourself do you find a need
for
for extending and retracting yeah
because just in the past year i've
gained 60 pounds and then lost it so you
know sure that can that's uh what
i've been wearing all kinds of sizes
absolutely well those are beautiful um
only matched by your natural beauty
so thank you for that nice to see you
here welcome everybody
by the way
quick shout out to bella simmons for a
hundred and fifty gifted subs
[Applause]
yeah
oh 100 total i see what's the deal are
they i mean thank you
thank you for the gifted also there's no
um ad today
so i want to give a quick thank you to
teddy fresh you know head on over
you never know what you're going to find
but you do know should we tell them
what's next week
you want to announce it here today sure
go ahead
next week drumroll on thursday
um i feel like you're you're so much
more epic you should say it you want me
to reveal it yeah a new collaboration
with teddy fresh coming
next thursday 10 a.m pst
teddy fridge.com we are happy and uh to
announce
the one and only
peanuts gang your favorite charlie brown
is coming
you
teddy fresh yes right snoopy woodstock
and all your favorite characters
and this guy of course will be
he's our he'll be uh going to your house
personally wait is that al roker
oh maybe
oh my goodness al
al roker will be coming to your house
personally to deliver can i poop
[Laughter]
dude you went too hard on this i'll be
honest you gotta you went too hard
back it up
al
i don't like
it but there you have it super fun it
came out great
so there you have it
wow we got a lot to do today
um
super excited we've been working on this
project ian and
and uh who was a bee or cam maybe went
to a crypto convention hey gabe and we
shot a whole
series about it you guys know how we
feel about crypto so
hilarity ensues gabe what's going on
buddy what you what you working on back
there
i'm i'm making lunch i'm making pasta
for lunch let me tell let me take a look
at that
okay are you just right
did you just reheat that or is that a
gabe original
it's kind of like a
it's kind of like both gabe original and
a reheat
does that mean you made it like last
night
yeah something like that something like
that
well what is it gabe i mean there is an
answer
i call it uh
uh
a penne um
meat sauce or a bolognese
who just walked by in the background
[Applause]
oh that's my uncle
hey uncle
can i get a woman can you give us a [ __ ]
lift up that pan
what how high is that flame at
is it not on gabe
kind of low if you put it too high it's
going to burn i don't think it's on barb
let's see the hole oh yeah yeah yeah it
is honestly
yeah if you put it too high you're gonna
have a barbecue penne no
bolognese barbecue you don't want it
barbecued oh no
all right any plans this weekend
well i'm promoting this new video of my
men it's called i'm red velvet by nick
nick nick nick garvey
[Applause]
is it out already
it's out already go check it out
nick nick's a prolific artist i mean he
it was just not that long ago that his
um
his other new single came out
let's take a look here
this is red velvet don't claim anything
you guys promise not to claim me right
yeah he said nah
you're not gonna block this video are
you gabe no we're not blocking it okay
all right i trust you
oh i see you finally got the uh
the street cred he said starring white
clogged it
you
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah but it says starring
he just says starring white claw gay but
i'm not
not quite seeing the starring role here
a role of a lifetime is this the
role of a lifetime i barely saw you man
he you got he can't abuse your name like
that
it's not the end you go to the end and
you see me sitting down that's like
would be the best part you know i'm
refusing to go to party and stuff and
i just like to get some ice cream and
then i'm sitting on the bench
okay let's see let's watch i want to see
that
[Music]
in the role of a lifetime white clock
[Applause]
i gotta say your boy has a has a
i think he's got a shot i'm not about it
i think i think nick nick has a future
in music i like this one yeah it's
working so hard
i pray for him the best
make it a hit baby [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
nick nick nick nick what red velvet oh
can i get that
red velvet
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right so if if nick nick goes big
are you are you his manager are you
getting a cut what's going on how are
you guys uh yeah what's the relationship
we're gonna work something out
we'll work it out yeah in some way
okay good yeah nick don't
[Music]
well this is very exciting good luck to
nick nick on a single red velvet it's
actually a bop and gabe it's always a
pleasure to hear from you on this
beautiful friday [ __ ] let me see the
pasta is it heated yet
it looks like it's heated up looks the
same
[Laughter]
are you sure it's on game
it's on it's heated up already sometimes
the gas runs but it doesn't light
oh yeah
yeah it must be my magic touch right
there
is it warm can you touch it just is it
warm or cold
that's warm
i'm doubting our boy i just don't know
it just looks like nothing happened in
the pan
i just want him to enjoy his pasta on
this friday
all right listen gabe you have fun
you enjoy we love you and we'll see you
uh next week all right you take care
yeah appreciate it the greatest that
ever did it
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're the best all right i'll talk to
you next week buddy
all right bye
[ __ ]
what a [ __ ] like
game there's no one like him
he's the goat man
he's honestly one of my best friends
at this point
i'm not even kidding he got cut out of
the bff uh podcast oh yeah yeah
his status is not ever in dispute he's
right tier above yeah he's asked here
friendship [ __ ] if i wasn't married he
might be my best man
the officiant
you guys should get divorced just to get
remarried can we yeah you can do that
yeah
but uh shout out okay so as i was
getting on um instead of renewing our
vows
just divorce
remarry right because it's got to be
it's got to be
it's got to be a real legal marriage
uh thank you to will uh will
ulstead who said i've watched every
episode for about a year and a half i
genuinely love everyone on the show
everyone brings their flavor and their
own touch to make the show truly special
thank you
for making the lonely times a little
less lonely thank you everything uh you
guys
that's why we do it
love you thank you bro
um
so
yeah we're gonna do the crypto
convention you guys know that's gonna be
good
also breaking news trump just got char
they [ __ ] released
the details
about why the fbi raided trump i thought
it was gonna be a nothing burger i'll be
honest
really
i did i thought they're like yo we need
the documents back he's not giving the
dog but i feel like the half the fbi
doesn't mess around for no reason do
they
like that's kind of hilarious it's gotta
be pretty serious
ah
i mean
i agree to raid ex-president you'd think
it would be like a really big deal i
think so well it turns out it is
they just uh released the
warrant warrant
and what's interesting about it is that
trump leaked it to breitbart as you know
credible publication with no slant legal
political agenda
and in their haste
they showed the crime he was suspected
of
which they probably didn't mean to do
because oh really once you look up the
penal code here let me pull this up here
you'll find yeah thank you dan once you
pull up the penal code here you'll see
here 18 usc whatever the what are those
[ __ ] like garlic s's i never knew me
neither
maybe it's called a
it's called a [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway uh that penal code if you look it
up is the mother loving espionage act
i'm deep undercover
which is so he totally did a self report
yeah
because the one that the doj released
probably did they not show that uh
that's a good question the news has been
so overwhelming about this breitbart
leak that i because they did just
release the
the actual release now i believe
and let me see if that's redacted
yeah this is kind of it's kind of
unbelievable what's happening so
it broke last night that trump
stole
top secret and classified documents wow
that pertain to nuclear secrets
which is kind of like the highest
guarded secret of national defense there
is here in america i mean why would you
take that home with you
there's no good there's no like good
reason right that can't be like what
that there's there's no kind of souvenir
it's a memento yeah self-defense the
launch codes just for old time's sake
if you're not president though can you
really do anything with those launch
codes no you're like alpha delta
i doubt it is mar-a-lago it's probably
uh with other
countries
yeah but i think they would yeah i don't
think they would actually be able to
just like call the white house and be
like here are the codes better launch
the nukes
but it's probably not launch codes it's
something
what's in there it's obviously a secret
right you know
well anyway so there was that and now we
find out that the warrant actually
says he's under investigation for the
[ __ ] espionage act which means he's
colluding with foreign adversaries
against the united states that's what
they suspect him of right which means
which means to me
that they may have found some intent for
him to
co uh collude with a foreign adversary
with these top secret documents either
to
uh through
you know
unconventional means back channels or
outright cell information or bargain
with it
because
how the [ __ ] else are they gonna charge
them from espionage
yeah that's super serious
you know you know what the crime is for
espionage ela
death
i would i was gonna say
that's gotta be a prisoner i know
they're not gonna kill him but
that's like just saying in extreme
nuclear codes that's straight death bro
a lot you know what these [ __ ]
russian spies were stealing uh state
secrets they got executed bro but when
you're like the president
um is there actually death penalty like
no right then definitely not that's he's
not imprisoned though could be
potentially i mean i don't think that'll
ever i'm still there yeah really
i mean i'm cynical enough to well i
don't think anything all happened to him
but it's still fine in israel that does
happen so right it's like i'm kind of
i'm used to that
in my opinion
our leaders being held accountable for
being you know psycho piece of [ __ ]
criminals is a sign of a healthy
democracy where nobody's above the law
it's israel how healthy it is but there
there are leaders in prison yes in
israel i wouldn't say it's a healthy
this government i want to live right
listen it's not good that he was elected
right but i want to live in a country
where our leaders are not are held
accountable or not just given a free
pass on any [ __ ] thing they do i mean
i i think it's weird that everyone's
response when i say prison you're all
like oh that's not gonna happen like
that's weird that [ __ ] yeah well well
it's never happened before yeah yeah
that's weird i mean
even nixon got up got out scot-free
pretty much
not pretty much he did yeah he got
bargained yeah
like it was just yeah nothing happened
to him
but uh anyway um
this is kind of nuts so
very nice
and then of course trump is pleading the
fifth
the other thing is the attorney general
i know you guys don't want me to talk
about this is like a leftovers thing but
i'm not waiting until thursday to talk
about it interesting
literally wondering what's happening you
know absolutely and it just broke like
30 minutes ago so it's brand new news
dude this is insane [ __ ] news you
guys this is obviously
i don't have commentary on the level of
uh
your auto co-host
what's the president [ __ ] that's crazy
yeah i like you being here i like your
perspective
but sounds not that interesting
i can't believe you measured his head i
don't know why i said that
how did you guys do that too well we
actually did a scientific analysis and i
don't know if you saw the conclusion of
it but he does have a small head and how
can you do that to him right i didn't
actually to be honest with you i
expected the results to be he has a
normal head
so i thought i was gonna be doing him a
favor right i love what he said though
how like no matter how you're going to
spin it whatever you guys were doing
felt pretty racist
just don't measure
just don't measure skulls yeah general
rule listen it wasn't we're not trying
to make any kind of assessment on skull
to intelligence yeah it was a
shoulder-to-skull ratio and his was not
good i didn't again i expected to uh
that's subjective i expected to not good
i expected to acquit him of any
suspicions of having a small head
of course he has a bigger head than me
he's [ __ ] 6'4
like a monster he's barely even human
cracker
like if they found hassan's skeleton 10
000 years from now next to like peter
dinklage they would think it's a
different race of man
he's very tall and he's not just tall
he's like
the ground shakes when he walks in here
and he goes
we can always hear him uh coming up the
stairs where he's clumping
i run away from my [ __ ] beanstalk
no he's so he's great everybody loves
everything about him everyone's thirst
strapping over him all i hear is his
son's so hot so he's fine
how about that he's
yeah he's built like a fridge thank you
i'd like to take that open and get kept
myself a coke zero you know what i'm
saying high-end fridge like the bigger
kind mm-hmm
big old samsung get me a sip of that
cool beverage inside
anyway uh
yeah sorry hassan i really didn't i
thought
i honestly thought we would be
acquitting him and people say well ethan
why don't you measure your hands then
against his and i say [ __ ] that bro i'm
not that would be fair it's not fair i'm
not doing it and that would be pretty
fair
no
i already admit i have small hands
taking something out no listen
saying
why was that thing so painful dude it's
super sharp it's like metallic and
i i believe this is for like
measuring automotive stuff no right that
makes sense not really intended for
uh we have a smaller one that we use for
measuring like accessories and things
yeah but um
listen i admit i have small hands uh
he insists that his head is normal so we
just wanted to crunch the numbers on
that
no more discussion about my hands
so anyway trump is the other thing about
this trump thing is apparently i've
heard is that merrick garland the
attorney general the guy who basically
has to sign off on all this
um
very cautious guy
he doesn't like to move without all of
his t's crossed as they say okay and um
this is really something incredible and
then they also revealed
that they took from mar-a-lago
dan you said they revealed just what
documents they got and what level of
classified they were the level of
classification yes what they were know
um because of course they are classified
so they they can't actually share what
the contents of them are the reporting
about it being nuclear material came
from a um
from like a leak essentially from
somebody
you know anonymously telling a reporter
that that is part of it so that is not
100 confirmed we should say oh it's not
confirmed
it's i mean it's being reported at
so-called reputable places um but it
again anonymously and
that information wasn't actually in the
documents that have been released
because again they can't actually say
what these documents are so that's um
that's not 100 confirmed
well what are they reporting
like i'm just kind of curious what
they're saying well they just said
sources sources have told us that um
some of the documents are related to
you know us weapons capabilities and
stuff like that that's so [ __ ] nuts
dude
uh well let me know if you get any other
yeah king update i'm keeping an eye on
the feeds the espionage ladies and
gentlemen
what's the last time someone got charged
for that in american history i'm deep
undercover it's been a minute that
that's the kind of charge you don't
really see every day
before yeah yeah for sure
thank you by the way to baxter lila it
looks like 1999.
i want to say david sheldon
david david david
some israeli got charged for it too
recently oh wait never mind
there's october 2 2002 anna montez 2009
stuart
knows that oh wait
one of the friend of the show chelsea
manning
oh yeah
[Music]
yeah chelsea was not executed so right
yeah but charged yes definitely charged
oh yeah she she got charged big time
well she was going to do life in prison
until obama commuted it right 2019 it
looks like was the most recent high
profile uh person charged with it
so there you go yeah i mean it does
happen but yeah it's certainly rare and
it's only used in
uh you know high level circumstances so
baxter's thank you because i want to say
thank you i love watching the podcast
and spending friday with you guys
also tia's the best he was a creative
genius
thank you master we love you baxter
while we're here
appreciate that
so moving on though we'll update if
anything comes on how it now this is for
me the big
breaking story i don't really care about
nuclear codes and all that [ __ ]
but how we finally got confronted on the
prolapsed anus and now i've been trying
yes thank you finally i don't know who
got this scoop
but i've been trying to get this story
i've been begging him to come onto the
show what do we do
in fact howie reached out to me and he
said
would you and ela like to come back on
the show i was like already howie
i said listen i will come in with ela if
you call in and talk about the prolapse
and he he didn't want to do it he didn't
no that was a good trade offer
see this
we're about to see why you messed up you
needed to ambush him with it you
couldn't yeah i don't want to do that to
howie
well i wouldn't ambush him then i get
yeah that's why you don't get the scoop
nah i wouldn't do that to poor howie
he's a good guy
like he ambushed me with that [ __ ]
prolapse on my for you feed
i don't know what this is from but it's
great
oh [ __ ] quick i know you gotta go you
probably are doing a bazillion of these
but you have to tell me
something producers are just going wild
behind the scenes oh um you kind of
broke tick tock howie what was up with
that video
nothing
that's so
[ __ ] funny
that's the best that's like a seinfeld
nothing
i love it
he's so embarrassed by it yeah i just
love how embarrassed he is
so good
yeah he told me he got
it which is kind of crazy surprising
nothing
oh that's a good sound bite though
i love that
oh you already grabbed it
oh yeah
nothing
[Laughter]
i don't think i was
i just do
that's great that's awesome
[Laughter]
five second pause nothing
it's almost like a little kid like if we
catch tiodor i feel like he would
say something like that like nothing
he wants to he wants to forget this
moment yeah but i think he need i really
think he should own it because it's so
legendary nothing but i like i like his
response because you also don't want
we've seen the meme become too aware
and that usually leads to like a i think
you start posting like even crazier
prolapses yeah or
not but i don't know just like oh you
like that he doesn't want to be a part
of it he doesn't want to become the
prolapse guy yeah
he could never
sally mendel
yeah but his life changed when he met me
in the malibu that one day i'm surprised
yeah so you're gonna have us back on the
podcast
i am too he seemed so nervous the whole
time but
i guess
but we're homies i mean we're dogs yeah
i would go whenever you want to go
that's what i said i said listen it's a
tip for that bro
i already did your show once now you owe
me a favor come talk about the prolapse
but he handled this so gracefully and i
think it's hilarious though shout out
howie tip of the prolapse to you
[Applause]
some people tip the hat oh god we
flicked the prolapse here in our show
and then our snack video did you talk
about how it came out and like yeah yeah
i did
it's my fave
i was sure they were going to cut that
out
i thought so too yeah
[Music]
anyway so that was exciting
another
philly d needs to
get off my nuts the kid in the blue gets
hit harder than i would hit ethan klein
if he put on his big boy pants and box
me which is saying something because
this morning i did three hole push-ups i
didn't even have to get up
by the way i love how these guys like
get in the shape of their lifetime and
then challenge me like philly used to be
a
skinny nose
push-ups but he's looking fit he could
do dude that man could do more it looks
like he's
yes he's lost a ton of weight and he
looks great the same thing with keemstar
it's like oh you're a [ __ ] tough guy
now
but what about when you were a lard ass
like me that's when we should be boxing
you know
getting all tough now
then
who who planted this idea didn't it come
from you
or from ian
ian planted it oh yeah ian asked if i
would box philip defranco
in creator clash
which is funny i mean it would be a
great fight it would be really funny but
i'm not doing it but look at him he's
already in shape it's not fair to me
he's way ahead of me in terms of
training you know what i mean
i'm not going to push you to doing it
because i don't want to see you get hit
thanks you'll appreciate that love you
so fine with me
yeah uh philly come on dude give me a
break
get in line everyone's trying to fight
me yeah i know
everyone's trying to [ __ ] me up even
howie said yo i'm gonna [ __ ] you up he's
gonna stop talking about the prolapse
threaten me
i said get in line hallie
you old ass nah he didn't threaten me
he said it's a he didn't threat he said
it's not a threat it's a promise so i
don't know if that's technically a
threat or a promise or how you
categorize that
so um
there's that
exciting stuff again
how we did a staples commercial i think
i'll [ __ ] claim me though for showing
it just watch the commercial just watch
the end here oh it's a prolapse yeah
very uh he's
he's on brand
wait did this just come out no this is
2021
oh we need to edit of this
this happens
we do not we need howie peeking out of
the prolapse
[Music]
yeah clearly i can but with great
reluctance i can do that
well
i leave it to you i i wouldn't force
any of my employees to look at a
prolapsed anus so i believe sam had to
stare at it for like 10 hours making
those donuts i definitely got the worst
listen listen
she couldn't use her imagination
i would never force her like clockwork
orange and force her eyes open look at
that she's a true artist yeah she is a
true artist
all right cam counting on you though i'm
on it already on i'm looking at it dead
in the eye right now i'm looking into
the abyss
give me damn granny what's up dude
taking this up
thank you for the gifted
maybe we should switch to order the
title back then
oh my god i don't think everyone cares
about trump
uh sure and then oh god dude this is
another fan favorite this came amazing
again this is a little leak over from
leftovers but i can't wait till thursday
to show this
a fan made this it only has 800 views
and it's like the best video i've seen
so
dark brandon do you know that meme
either no i've missed that meme well you
know what the brandon meme is right no
oh so
dude it's so stupid um
republicans say let's go brandon which
apparently means [ __ ] joe biden in
secret um what was the what's the lore
there there was an announcer
it was a nascar driver right and that
what's the best chanting
let's go brandon it sounded like [ __ ]
you biden or something no it was the
opposite there was a bunch of people
were chanting at some sporting event
[ __ ] joe biden
and
the announcer or somebody was like
they're chant they're all chanting let's
go brandon and they thought that was
hilarious so they just adopted it and
started using that as code to say [ __ ]
joe biden basically which is actually
funny because that libs ended up liking
it as much as they they do and now we
turned it into dark brandon which is
like successful joe biden this has been
a hell of a month for dark brandon so
what's dark brandon
he's like fallen snake he's like
he's like vanquished
basically it actually it started
as parody of all of the memes of trump
being like the god emperor
trump and like you know this golden holy
being or whatever
and people sort of satirically where
like and
from what i understand the origin of it
is people that don't even necessarily
like joe biden you know people far left
that think that he's not nearly left
enough and they're like
satir like ironically hyping them up
like joe biden is is this badass who's
going to like execute
all of the republicans and he's going to
work you know bring in the world new
order and uh all that kind of stuff yeah
but now it's kind of uh evolved beyond
that and just the general you know all
democrats find it hilarious and have
been turning it around
come on man
come on man
yeah so it's like a really beautiful
turn of events for the libs and it's
like reclaiming
reclaiming the meme for ourselves you
know what i mean yeah
so here is a fan made edit this is one
of the best i've seen
um
let's go dark brandon
was making a speech
and uh
i had a terrible headache here
i'm tired
i'm sick and tired
[Laughter]
mr president
wake up okay get to work
there's so much more to be done
that's dark branching
three people have died from last night's
lightning strike happened just outside
the white house
i thought i heard him rumbling my staff
saying oh he's back
seemed to support some guy named dark
brandon
wait he's having a really good year
look at this what was him saying
wait bro you missed my favorite joke
wait did joe did he really say dark
brandon no it's manipulated yeah okay
really [ __ ] clean though yeah this
character is insanely talented
seem to support some guy named dark
brandon he's having a really good year
coven neutralized gas prices
shinzo abe neutralize what the [ __ ]
that's a bunch of milwaukee a.r.a funded
baby
[Applause]
[Music]
can't be pro-insurrection and
pro-democracy you can't be
pro-insurrection and pro-america
donald trump like
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh my god
yo straight up shout the [ __ ] out
to the export
how good was that man yeah so much fun
yeah that is a fupa trooper he uh he
dm'd it to me um he had another one that
i think we watched on the show maybe let
me see that was like the sleepy joe
biden that that went really uh
viral
shout out to my boy for making a ethan
klein most savage moment oh let's go
savage compilation check it out
um
savage compilations of me i feel like
i'm worse
yeah looks so good
[Laughter]
where's the puppet grab the puppet no we
can't show that oh yeah turn it off
okay i don't think he showed that
i got to make sure let's not watch
savage moment maybe i'm two savage two
seven two savage for tv i just got
banned the last time yeah anyway shout
out to the uh export wow i'm a [ __ ]
savage you gotta do it
okay also breaking news from um
from the family first and foremost a b
oh okay yeah there's that one that's
really interesting you know that that's
about what you've done with that
love that might be a good one to tweet
out
yeah that's an art that's a really
interesting interpretation of the events
that happened
i really had to rack my brain and make
it safe for the show yeah fantastic i
think
that's really good we should send that
to howie yeah
send it to him
also a huge update from ab who's going
to be back next week he's at the local
butcher no no no
more than that family childhood butcher
that's right securing the meat shout out
to ronnie berry's halal meat
jerky
ab is securing the meets ladies and
gentlemen
and he's actually someone died here so
i haven't got it
i haven't gotten around to cleaning but
detroit is a rough city
so we uh look forward to abey's return
and leaners of course yeah mostly lena's
we kid the ones we love you know that
uh
all right
and
basically
people are asking for a jeep update
yeah
so
basically um
oh real quick just
mentioned because somebody just messaged
me the guy that made the joe biden meme
he's watching right now he's in the chat
oh hey got out dude
[ __ ] love your ass that was great
talent
raw on mitigate i like to export that
talent
yeah so for people that didn't uh see
the show on wednesday right was it you
know
there was a insane
uh
chat fundraiser for sam's
dream
jeep ladies and gentlemen
and the top so
i gotta so there's a youtube 30 cut
right then
that's correct so after youtube's 30 cut
what was the um the total scrolling up
right now
the grand
total was
three thousand eight hundred and twenty
three dollars and sixty four cents and
plus five crazy so about four thousand
oh plus your 100 right right so just a
shy just a hair shy of four thousand i
like to mention that so you guys don't
forget i did that gave her 100 out of my
pocket oh yeah i didn't forget thank you
sam
yeah yeah 30 is robbery i agree
but that's youtube for you i mean that's
crazy youtube goes that's what it is on
twitch i was like man
shut up i yelled them all the time
shut up i'm like there's a reason i'm
not on twitch
so stupid how much they take
uh especially when it's like a straight
donation to user does twitch take from
donations
no
yeah so what the [ __ ] are they doing
taking from well it's not a donation
it's a it is a donation super chat
though it's a super chat wait twitch
doesn't take a cut of donors well most
people don't use the intricate
integrated donation system they use like
a paper regulated paper right yeah it
goes directly
yeah but they also have a built-in
system that takes like 50 i think so 50
oh my god
okay fair enough yeah i mean i like i do
like the super chat system that they
have
it just kind of sucks that
it's 30. i feel like they could give the
the creators a nicer cut it is actually
better than twitch because unlike
members for example twitch is 50 and
only top creators get 70
they give everybody seven percent
actually the membership you mean i'll
throw you another curveball on this okay
and i had no way of calculating this so
we're just going to have to roll with it
but
anybody who is on an iphone and donates
on an iphone oh [ __ ] apple takes a cut
of the super chat as well
wow
[ __ ]
that's what they do on cameo any
transaction on an iphone
takes a cut [ __ ] apple yeah isn't
that [ __ ] so wait what does apple
take thirty percent how do you do it
i don't know
i do it on my phone apple takes 30
yeah top oh
[ __ ] bro so they they
youtube specifically said they take
their 30 second so apple takes their 30
off and then whatever's left youtube
then takes 30 of that and then you get
the remainder that's crazy dude apple
actually the way that they run their
platform is so
[ __ ] up it's actually a huge problem
why did they get a percentage of that
they they have this [ __ ] where
anything that's downloaded from the app
store the apple app store they get a 30
cut of every transaction
and epic games had actually a lawsuit
with them i don't know what was the
result of that i think they just pulled
off completely
they just said [ __ ] yeah fortnight is no
longer on the ipads wow
yeah but it's super i mean that's so
much
it's super [ __ ] up because if you use
a reason they're the biggest company in
the world right i guess so i thought it
was off from phones but apparently it's
stealing money from sam
right right
you really really
tim apple
um
but
if you if you
buy [ __ ] with an android
there's no cut
these guys learned it the hard way on
cameo when people buy with a android you
get way more money than when people do
it on an apple isn't that right zach
yeah
what a nice
apple takes 25 on cameo
so anything they take a cut i didn't
know that if someone buys a cameo on
their iphone
uh all in all i think our cut is like 45
yeah wow less than half it's awesome
dude
that's helpful i stopped using cameo
[ __ ] that
well it's kind of crazy when you learn
like how many how many people wet their
beak before you even get paid yeah not
to mention taxes which comes down later
yeah i had to pay 50 taxes on top of
that oh my god what do you what do you
end up making like two bucks from a ten
dollar
yeah i mean like two bucks in your
pocket i feel i felt weird putting it
higher up so i
ended up doing them for super cheap and
then i just ended up turning it off or
not using cameo
yeah
so there you have it so
so wait if that's after apple's cut
yeah it's got to be the 39 or whatever
sam got yeah and i just did the mat so
the 30 plus
30 again means it's uh 49 of the
donation
that's [ __ ] good congratulations to
apple everybody
on their new beef yeah
tim apple and susan wojcinski the proud
owners of new electric jeeps
[Laughter]
yeah so you she got four thousand
dollars and i want to say first of all
for the record sam never asked anybody
to donate a dime
okay one person was doing a meme and
said here's five bucks for sam's jeep
because she was talking about her dream
car was an electric jeep and then it
turned into this donation train where
everyone was just having fun
and trying to hook up sam she never
asked for shits
and there are some people
uh i'm not naming names
except you matthew watching you son of a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm not naming names but there are
people who are like
trying to make sam
feel bad
when she
literally didn't even ask for it just
let her have a w let her enjoy this
moment without [ __ ]
making her feel bad guys please it's not
fair
yes so and and i guess i don't know sam
if you want to talk about your plan for
that
you know thank you so much to everyone
that donated that's very sweet not
necessary super sweet though um i really
appreciate that um
i'm going to i'm shopping around right
now i'm trying to sell my car currently
and
once that happens and then you know all
the donations i'll absolutely put
towards that um i can't do it right now
obviously but
that's my long-term plan so
what a plan what a plan folks
let's get that g-baby
and you know i just know that if we
didn't say something people are like yo
what the [ __ ] happened to that g where's
the jeep well it's it's cheap money it's
worth the dressing too because
also not naming names but i saw
some people
uh
asking like oh i wonder if they'll
announce that she got her jeep on
friday's episode mm-hmm no it doesn't
happen
it was two days ago it's not that easy
to get the jeep first of all even if she
was ready right i mean it depends
also a lot of cars there's a long
waiting list i don't know how this works
this is a new car yeah so they're
selling out i see like 25 every day with
dealership tags like they're they're
gone as soon as the dealership gets them
they're gone by the way i wasn't here
for that conversation but i want to say
that i love that car too
yes and i think all of us
were saying earlier we all want to have
one and that was like a pink one not
really but i want like a neon i was
thinking about it like a neon lime
next to my pink car that would look so
good
we should all get one yes i'm kind of
thinking about
what kind of cash windfall would i need
to buy everyone in an electric eevee
you want to talk about it i don't know
they're about
54 or 56 msrp so so as we're looking at
like probably after tax and everything
like three four hundred thousand elena
and av want one too yeah of course they
do
cameron you're getting one too don't
worry
thank you
yeah but i'm just wondering what kind of
windfall can we uh
can we expect i can't tell well that'd
be like one day of profit for uh
infowars yeah maybe we need to just
start selling uh dude a bunch of
supplements in uh slot buckets and [ __ ]
i'm trying to convince hassan that we
need to create some dumb product for
leftover
parody
all the [ __ ] that the conservatives show
that is true that would be funny oh
people are saying steak take a steak
deal
all you have to do is gamble 18 hours a
day [ __ ]
well apparently if yeah i mean if
they'll pay me 2 million dollars in a
month
yeah and i'm gonna keep [ __ ] gambling
that's a lot of electric jeeps
anyway so that's it that's the update i
just want you guys to know we'll keep
the jeep updates
coming
but is ian also interested in the jeep
or oh it's all good i have a skateboard
yeah but for real sam she was she was
stressing last night i was like you know
like it's okay you know feeling the
pressure a little bit what were you
worried about sam specifically um
buying a car just feeling like pressured
to you know goodbye to car yeah yeah or
not yeah it's just um
i don't know i'm trying to sell my car
first and that's a whole thing in itself
so
yeah i don't know i've never bought a
car before like a new car so
yeah it's uh very scary i was worried
because yeah like you said buying a new
car is a lot and also an electric jeep
is it a very expensive car
and i was just like i don't know if the
money i i just don't i want everyone's
expectations to be in the right place
for that so sam
shout out
god bless
and all that same temple think of the
gifted sub
slam was very nice of you guys by the
way touching
moving uh incredible thing i got a i got
an email though from a young boy named
tim he actually couldn't afford his
cancer medicine that day
and he actually i think he said that's
our joke
yeah he couldn't afford it while we were
raising money for sam's gl absolutely
his uh his uh he actually was writing me
as the um
hit the chemotherapy ivy ran out of
fluid uh he said damn there's no more
fluid i can't afford it i'm sorry i'm
going to get pissed off but i come with
your jeep he's like i guess i'll just
die anyway congratulations on the jeep
sam
[Applause]
thank you thank you
what the dude we can't save every kid
with cancer
people need cars
also can i add about the the jeep yeah
if people expected it to come too soon
and you were one of the ones who donated
wouldn't you much rather have your money
go to a like into a smarter purchase
that isn't rushed
of course of course of course yeah don't
rush anything sam
yeah all right
yeah i'm i'm 100 planning on getting it
and i was shooting for like early next
year end of this year but uh just
depends on when my car sells honestly
that's going to be so exciting yeah i
can't wait i'm so excited and like you
guys pushed me a little bit closer and
that's awesome and i'm very grateful for
that love that
hey i'm so excited so gosh we have so
much to get to
uh one other thing i don't know when you
guys want to do this but i saw a tick
tock on this i thought it'd be fun us
reviewing our favorite chex mix pieces
oh because i saw i thought in my mind
there's one
correct answer and everything else is
wrong okay
but they had a big diversity of answers
which kind of surprised me
so i don't know if you guys want to do
this real fast because i'm kind of i
could use a snack at this moment
sure why not
we all have some text messages i took a
poll before the show um that i don't
know
oh i won't i get don't reveal it yet
okay i won't
yeah so we can do another one i'll go
first because i'm really passionate
about it okay
now
of all the pieces of checks
can you put up pull up like a diagram of
all the pieces yeah um here let me the
tick tock that you saw is in the dock
and it's got a nice little layout of all
the options here so
there it is there's the
mini breadstick
the ride chip
square pretzel corn chex we check circle
pretzel
i in my mind there's one
answer that's correct i mean you're
looking at an s plus here versus like c
tier minus
for me it's obviously the right chip wow
you're one of those people
what is happening right now
shoot that ride chip into my veins i
want a bag of just rag chips because
everything else is [ __ ] filler i
agree with you yeah right chip
right chip and then second i would say
is the
check square i'm right with you you know
but this is only like
you're only eating the corn checks to
get to the ratchet to make more space
for the ratchet i want to say
the the pretzels
and the mini breadstick are basically
trash wow i'll tell you i'll eat those
ones this one's stretched to me
dude
is [ __ ] [ __ ]
literally who cares this is literally
putting garbage inside of a snack bag
like why are you putting this in this is
trash it's an insult
go ahead my bag doesn't even have a rye
chip in it dude really yeah me too i
just had one
whoa that's [ __ ] insane you know why
because they're not the best one okay
what's your favorite
um definitely the
czech square both of them
yes
they're a beautiful
consistency
stunning crunch
it's stunning and they're like a little
bit sweet kind of
i like the corn one the wheat one
i can't say anything good about it
nothing uh-oh not even the the crunch
nothing good i don't mind it i like both
i like both too yeah to me they taste
the same yeah no
come on
stop it you've got elevated taste buds i
guess
anyone else
i hate the pretzels
i hate the breakfast
and packed right now they are so soft
damn if you want pretzels you gotta eat
only pretzels
i stand within it on the president
they don't make a little bit together
the texture is not good on the predator
right yeah if you're gonna have a
pretzel disagree let it not be dusty
first of all why not
it tastes better without the dust
if you're eating the chex mist you're
eating it partially for the dust all of
them have dust i agree
you got to be equal opportunity
the chex
square and the right shape are also
crunchy and then the pretzel feel like a
grandma yep
for reals call me now
banana okay so so sam what's your
favorite
ride chip gang right yup guys dude i
knew you had a woman of class so i gotta
say
most people are with you oh yeah
if you look at the comments this is what
blew me away last night and we were
talking about in our crew chat
because when you sent this i went down
to the comments
it's all rye chips they're right it's
all right right chip only right chip's
the only correct answer obviously the
right chip right and that i don't
i'm
i i like all of the pieces in there
maybe not the breads the breadstick kind
of sucks yeah it's really simple but
everything else i'm okay with but i had
no idea there was this level of support
for the rideship
it really blew my mind did you what was
the pull uh the results oh the ride trip
did win um not as commanding as those
comments would imply we have 32 percent
right chip okay 25 check piece
uh i didn't um
distinguish between the wheat and the
corn there weren't enough options so i
just said the check piece uh pretzel and
then
correctly the mini breadstick is down
here at the bottom still decent amount
of people have anyone even voted for it
it's 18 that's something breadstick it's
almost one in five yeah like the
breadstick well like i'm at a dinner
table and i get like a loaf of bread or
something like a [ __ ]
what does a loaf of bread for ant
anyone else got want to share their
opinion i'll start off by saying that i
hate chex mix
wow what um
yeah just straight up i [ __ ] hate it
but the only reason i would eat it
is for the rye chips
okay
that's un-american
you sure you're american
i don't know
do they have this in sweden well
i mean
not really i mean we do have it i guess
it's just a mix of ships or like
um what is it i don't even know what it
is
it's like there's a snack bag yeah like
a healthy mix of stuff
but honestly if someone has this at a
party i'd be kind of sad honestly it
would be way better to have like a bag
of ships or something thank you chex mix
it's just depressing
yeah it's like um
airplane uh
you get it on airplanes
i get i guess i'll eat it it's above
that i think that's below chuck's mix i
don't know i don't know
i like the cheddar chex mix the most
those are the best
the cheddar cheddar is good i think it's
a great late night snack but or with
alcohol
great yeah if you're drunk
there's a bowl of chex mix don't pretend
like you're not just
the cheddar one doesn't have rye chip
though so
oh
problem
all right well there you go at least
most people are sane and say right chip
i don't know what it is about the right
chip i don't even love rye bread i don't
like this brown dark red texture there's
just something incredible about it no
crunchy it's everything
well i've uh thrown up another live poll
and the results are pretty much the same
the right chip is dominating at 43
followed by the checks pieces followed
by the pretzel
and the mini breadstick down there at
the bottom where it belongs
curse that thing
why would you mix checks pieces wheat
and corn that's insane there's only four
options available on the polls on
youtube so i just
i mean because there's also pretzels
there's two shapes of pretzels okay even
can you close your eyes and have one and
tell me if it's wheat or not wheat yeah
dude i can tell
good idea no way good idea yeah 100
here no i have it i have it no more so
i've been challenged by olivia
she really thinks i can't tell the
difference between wheat and corn chex
make
checks
that's a simple task
let's do four rounds two of each agreed
ready go ahead
we
really
what'd i say did i stutter
[Laughter]
ready
wait you can clear it up
[Music]
corn
corn
is he right yep wow
okay you proved me wrong last one one
more
beautiful
wow
wow come on
i'm really good pro
i honestly didn't even know there were
two kinds in the background
no literally neither i knew that there
were different colors i didn't realize
yeah sweet and one wasn't wow i thought
it was for decoration i have a hidden
talent
i didn't know about it
what what is the difference
the wheat's texture is like
way more dense little grainier the
flavor
it's sweeter which i don't like
big difference is how you pay it back
okay well that was fun
a little unexpected trip
down check lane
can you bring me back a donut dealer
sam keeps bringing donuts why do you do
that
it's friday
friday baby night
real quick i [ __ ] up my pretzel toss
the last time can i get a redemption
real quick hold on
let's see it
i got it yo
[Applause]
stuck in my throat
rap
what is with this thing it just gets
caught slammed in there
because it's so dry
[Laughter]
it won't come out i don't know heimlich
do you need the heimlich i've never
heard of the heimlich
okay funny
it's just a little flake that's jammed
in my throat it's not choking me it's
just
oh my god it won't move
where's ab when you need him oh i got a
piece
i think i got it you got it yeah
i'm saying the weed checks are dangerous
i got it
you're right
i'll keep an eye out
do you have your checks mix
do you have any right chips left girl
leave
do you have your passport
did you get your shots
girl would you like to come back with
rob to america
[Music]
do you have your passport
did you pick your shots
girl would you like to come back with
rob to america
america
do you have your passports did you get
your shots
girl would you like to come back
[Music]
to america
[Applause]
rest in peace to the goat
you think he's getting all of that
sentence was wrong
rest in peace not goat nah
well r.i.p to the go do you think he's
getting any conjugal visits
i hope not yeah i also is he allowed
those as a like predator i wonder
you'd think you would think but
i don't know i'd assume
i guess maybe everybody doesn't get
visiting privileges
i don't know
um
oh my god you actually brought me a
donut
thank you queen
sam did this
do you
um it's i don't it's more about the
gluten i really wish i could have it but
so you feed me
and you don't even touch it i feed
everyone here that's a little suspicious
everything's about me
i did have a bite but
i just don't want to eat too much
[Music]
maybe that's all you get that's it
[Music]
what
what
no
was it me
it was not me
[Music]
dan explain what happened i'll convey it
to you what happened dan's upset
he's coming over he's also not wearing
shoes which is kind of odd
you have no shoes on it
there's just multiple doughnuts with a
single bite taken last night
or donuts i did not
anybody want to tell me my mics muted um
i opened you up okay
uh there
are four
donuts every time i open the box with
just one giant bite taken out of it and
i gotta be honest i think it's ethan i
think it's ethan i would be honest i
don't okay go ahead olivia say it thank
you
you did it
i'll accept your apology dan okay i
apologize all right go ahead thank you
it seems like anything it wasn't me last
week i promise what about last week did
you do a last week
i was like oh wait you took them you
know at least when i do it well most
people don't like jelly donuts so that's
why i was like i'll pull a tiny piece
off of the jelly you didn't bite it no
that's a [ __ ] criminal man i'm super
sorry i didn't want anyone to know when
i do it
i use a knife
i take a clean little piece off
and i even put the knife next to it so
people know
there was no slobber on it okay would
you would you do that to pizza these are
so good by the way like what would you
do that to pizza ethan just cut a little
bit off or whatever if i'm going to cut
a little slice i would go vert you know
that way so the slice still looks legit
that's criminal i'm sorry man how's that
criminal it's exactly criminal
it's criminal this is a smaller slice
disagree what's the you want to debate
me what's wrong with taking a vertical
slice you either take the slice or you
don't what
there's no picking you can't pick that's
wasting food i'm sorry zach but you're
you got to take the l on this one i'm
i'm not taking the l
you're not destroying it's not like a
donut i do that a lot because i don't
want to eat a whole slice dude a donut's
a circle
you can't repair a circle
the pizza
is a triangle you cut down the triangle
it's still a triangle did you do it with
a pizza cutter like they present it to
you or you take a knife and do it i do
it good okay no matter i would like to
see that i would like to see that you
don't think it's possible to cut down a
piece of smoke no i've never seen it
before really yeah
i'm sorry it's criminal so you're saying
it's impossible to cut down a piece of
slice clean yes with like a [ __ ]
butter knife or something i don't use a
butter what do you use that you think i
am what are you using i don't know a
sharp knife
okay fair
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's not taking too much [ __ ] today for
me
[Laughter]
anyone else
anyone's got some [ __ ] to say
that cream one's good you know it's so
good i'm i am and i'm taking it away
with me
i love dunkin donuts that's all i gotta
say
it was me last week i took the bite
and i put it back
thank you so much for saying that i am
prosecuted unfairly dan did you hear
that i was gonna come in and defend you
okay you waited pretty long sam
yeah but it's criminal my friend
i didn't want to interrupt
hilarious
dan did you hear that
[Music]
yeah he disappeared that man is walking
around the office with no shoes by the
way
casual friday
is he in the bathroom with no shoes
no our bathroom's clean i mean
it's still kind of weird though
i would yeah i gotta find out if he wore
shoes into the bathroom at least
um
sam you admitted that when dan is not
here i noticed that
he didn't need to hear it
also everyone in the chat is saying i'm
gross i cut it i don't just take a bite
with my mouth and put the doughnut back
in the box then it's completely fine
what the hell yeah it's fine i
personally think it's totally fine i
agree and then everybody then you'll
have a communal donut that everyone can
take a little piece out of yeah because
it's like it's a lot of food
a whole donut is a serious undertaking
sam damn are you in the bathroom right
now and were you you weren't wearing
shoes in the bathroom
he wasn't wearing dude what the [ __ ]
that's weird man
think about it dan was in the bathroom
with no shoes
[Music]
so much is being revealed today and
something else well because it's
unsanitary
something else zach you have to zach
your toe is rotting perfect
at least i wear shoes in the [ __ ]
bathroom
how much has that helped you
i'm not getting [ __ ] like i'm not
getting like [ __ ] no fungus dance
fungus
i know i noticed a little like fungus on
your feet walking around on [ __ ]
barefoot
i'm not worried about the i just i'm
worried about dan's foot not listen i'm
acknowledging it yeah that was that was
a bad move i'm not defending it
like he took a walk on the wild side and
i appreciate that oh it was just a
little real quick didn't you
maybe we can
we can leave slippers outside the
bathroom for everybody oh interesting
uh sam is there something you want to
say before we move on
uh
nope
last week it was me about the donut dan
i think you should apologize to ethan i
already did i already apologized to
ethan
you apologize for the olivia accusation
i i may have been spoken over but i did
say
ethan
i am so sorry that i assumed
that you were the one
taking big bites out of the donuts and
leaving them in the box
i admit
i made it an assumption i i've seen you
hover across the room
when there's a warm pie
now you have it with the smell
lines going up your nose you haven't
been fluttered
i don't know why people always make
these stuff it's a good apology it's
just why it's just not fair i mean
everyone just what was blame the fat guy
is that the is that the idea yeah it's
just
you guys who found the vlog to be
offensive i'm sorry you did for those of
you who didn't know the defensive i'm
sorry at least you didn't do like a fake
apology that was a real apology
yeah but he didn't say like i'm sorry
you feel this way yeah that's true you
did own it
but for the record i don't think sam or
olivia did anything wrong if you take a
bite and put it back you're mentally ill
yes dan i cut the doughnut i didn't take
a bite and put it back
sorry
[Laughter]
i like sound bites sorry dad can i get
one of those zach
sorry all right
that felt real that felt good
can i put in a formal request though in
the office if we are gonna be picking
off pieces of the donut just let
everyone know so it doesn't look like uh
how do we how can we how can we
symbolize it leave a note like you hit
someone's car you leave a note yeah
yeah just so we know it's not a bite
well what i do
we all have to assume it's not a bite
what i do that i think is a good
conveyor
leave the leave this
tool that was used next to the donut
you can see the remnants of the cut but
that's fair
that tool may move over time and then
it's not going to be there at some point
right somebody could [ __ ] it up but i
think in general leave the tool
and then other people can use it as well
sorry yeah it's okay
we're all learning
all right enough
away with you
uh donut discussion
we have so much to talk about my
goodness
can i say uh housewives of beverly hills
suck
i'm really not enjoying this season
and
i stopped watching that [ __ ] i can't do
it i hate diana
and i hate kyle and lisa rayna
and basically erica
so your left weight is just satin and
garcelle
and yeah that's all i have to say thank
you
yeah by the way i know you have back
pain elo yeah
i found i just thought this was on my
feed this morning the new chiropractor
unlocked by the way ladies i don't know
if you know this but you can wear
clothing to the
chiropractor
you can't wear what you can wear
clothing when you're uh
just
as a public service announcement
for some reason all these videos these
women are stripped bare and i'm just
saying that
i wonder why
you don't have to do that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
why is she naked
right
he literally just punched her in the
back
[ __ ]
dude i can't convey enough how much
chiropractors are total charlatans in
fact
i've been reading more and more about
like first of all you can't they're the
adjustments aren't real
there's no such thing as an adjustment
bones don't move like that okay you
can't adjust someone's back
period it doesn't it's not a thing
and second of all
i feel like the more i read the more i
find out that this kind of chiropractor
there's like physical therapy which is
good
which is like science based
but this kind of [ __ ]
is going to [ __ ] your body up more
you're going to be walking out of there
with lifelong
trauma to your body this man has just
punched her in the back
what are we doing
this is like caveman [ __ ] it makes no
sense
actually caitlyn probably would know not
that they'll be like don't make any
sense
this man is just
[ __ ]
dropping a hammer on her back
but the fact also that it's being
recorded and that she's not really
wearing clothes is pretty annoying it's
the it's the whole
triple threat yeah you've got psycho
chiropractor
uh a girl in underwear
it's all happening
dude he hit her
okay here we go i'm going to pull your
arm as hard as i can
[Music]
guys guys
it's time we all be real about what's
going on here
this guy how the [ __ ] is this helping
her like just use your brain just use
your brain okay
just think about it your arm hurts right
let's do this
okay guys let's just think for a sec
that's not helping
how's that helping
[Music]
i'm curious what you guys think do you
guys think that is an actor because i'm
almost certain of it being an actor i do
the girl or the chiropractor the girl
i think he actually hurt her
no sure but no there's she's an actor
what of course yeah i don't see why
would she want to be in this video she
might be an actor but i think he's
really doing chiropractic [ __ ] on her
she's like no yeah yeah she's been
getting paid yeah to be there he's doing
the things too yeah
yeah of course i mean
you don't have clients like this walking
over the street but this is what they do
this is real chiropractic yeah yes he's
not like he's actually he's actually
hurting her i mean he just punched her
in the [ __ ] back
but of course i checked out his whole
page and it's
it's incredible this guy's clientele he
is so
yeah isn't it incredible what this niche
is huh
incredible
he's got this he's a man of culture girl
by the way i don't gotta who would you
ever go to the uh chiropractor in a
bikini
or is that underwear
i don't know
it's like a swimsuit it looks like a
bikini
yeah so these are all really good but
that was my fave
i mean i've tried chiropractor once we
went together but they didn't ask me to
take off my clothes
uh
yeah
but he was some old weirdo israeli dude
they just they learned all of them like
40 to 50.
oh like ethan i don't know no no no
what anyway they they just learn
they know the names of the muscles and
joints and they just learn a way to
[ __ ] talk to convince you that
they're like doctors and what the [ __ ]
they're doing they don't
look at this [ __ ]
it was before this man just punched her
in the back
yeah right watch this again
[Music]
like if you have back pain how is that
going to help it's not it's going to
make it worse
i mean you might as well just say hey
you know what the cure to back pain is
getting rear-ended by a car it doesn't
even sound like anything cracked like he
just whacked her
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
no no he was administering a
chiropractor to you actually
yeah she looks super happy about that by
the way
uh this procedure we are trying to sever
uh we're trying to adjust the spinal
cord and sever ties to the brain
if you become a quadriplegic it will
cure your back pain technically
it's [ __ ] awesome
this man they're like they're laughing
but that's just like like a way to cope
with shock yeah
right
so [ __ ] up yeah here's the one with
three million you know it's gonna be
good
girl do you know you're wearing a bikini
[Music]
this is his special move you'll notice
he
has developed this
and uh
it's it's patented
it's called the uh body it's called the
uh
fist to the back
[ __ ] friday baby
[Music]
not again
[Music]
you know why she feels maybe better it's
because she's got like adrenaline
running because you just got punched in
the back twice
and it stopped so she's relieved
shit's crazy guys
i'm telling you don't do that [ __ ] just
go see a physical therapist
trying to save you
guys i'm confused who is watching it
and i kind of don't want to know
well it seems to be like weirdly
aggressive towards her
yeah it
it may be a fetish thing there in that
case i mean there's a whole we've seen a
whole
vertical of videos of like
chiropractors adjusting scantily clad
women yeah but usually
i didn't feel like it was aggressive
like this
like
that one he's just punching her in the
back
well i don't know play the do the button
one dan do you have that button program
still
i don't but i was one step i'm looking
for it right now yeah well you say you
haven't seen chiropracti chiropractory
that oh i found it that violent well i
don't know either what is this
oh god
this is the ultimate adjustment
this is my favorite [ __ ] video now
that's what i call an adjustment
we need this we need this device in
every chiropractor office around the
world one more time dan
you got back pain
drawing quarter his ass
[ __ ]
these people have lost their [ __ ]
mind god damn
these chiropractors need to be stopped
like period
yeah you know what they used to call
chiropractors in uh ancient days
torturers
you hear that tortures yeah
thank you
thank you thank you a couple more
stories and we'll get to the crypto
convention
i thought this was funny
joe rogan
friend of the show
tweeted this he's always on this man is
on top of his [ __ ]
say what you will about joe rogan but
look at this
revealed after 32 years the top secret
picture one mod insider called the most
spectacular
ufo ufo photo ever captured
easter eyes my friends
on a [ __ ]
like 1950s flying saucer man
is i mean is this a joke
also what's this website mail plus it's
the daily mail
that's a tabloid right yes
dude stop it bro
[ __ ] you you just this is like the gr
and what the [ __ ] is this dude
this is the best the government the
whole world has gotten
after
32 plus years of researching
[Music]
the original calvin photograph showing
the diamond-shaped craft and a hairier
aircraft than what appears to be close
proximity this is clearly way behind it
what are you talking about
appears is key there's always the sfa
aspect perhaps it's a rather drab kite i
mean it could be the point is
it's
who thinks this is convincing it looks
like dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah scientists
are in tears
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is so stupid
what a idiot forget about james webb
let's see
oh
they hear people have heard they figured
it out guys it's this
sick
yeah i want to see if anyone's like yo
this is the dumbest tweet ever
i think those people already left his
twitter a while ago
[ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway i thought that was funny i wanted
to share it with you guys
the ever mentally uh
sharp joe rogan ladies and gentlemen
well with that all being said
um it's time
for us to take a little visit to the
crypto convention now let's see ian you
want to explain a little bit basically
what is this specific convention you
guys went to
uh yeah this one is actually nft expo so
it has a focus on the nft aspect
of the crypto world which is thriving
and uh thriving yes we figured
you know we had no ads on this episode
our ads have been a little lighter so we
thought we would go and
try and generate some revenue make some
money baby
how did you find out about the nft expo
uh i actually heard it on the radio oh
on the way to work yeah how was it
marketed
it's just like you know some cyber music
and like come on down
right all the you know panels are gonna
be popping
the web is gonna be 3.0
all that good stuff what do they call it
web three or some [ __ ] yeah web three
the new world
the final says just got back from
deployment thank you so much appreciate
you well without further ado
ian and ab present
the crypto convention
nft style baby all right
we're here looking for some ways to
generate some revenue for the h3 podcast
what better way than the reliable
the foolproof world of nfts and so we've
come to nft expo we're going to step
into the future for this very special
occasion i wanted to bring a very good
close personal friend of mine mr api on
please come come come in ian lied to me
he said we're just hanging out
and he gave me this t-shirt asked me to
put it on what do you mean
what is the problem you know i thought
we would hang out for once i don't want
to be here can i talk to you for a
second oh i don't want to [ __ ] be
here i don't care this is my weekend
what did you just wear the dink dog
shirt i didn't know there's a ding dong
come back oh we're going to redo it this
[ __ ] is embarrassing i'm here with my
close personal friend baby i uh what's
up everybody we're good sell some nfts
as you remember i gifted ap some nfts
for christmas that's right the
sensational shoe and the frenching
fathers best gift ever so today i'm
gonna need you to go sell
it's a those over the top
just tone it down too low too high what
do you want from me we're gonna sell
some nfts
[Music]
so wait are these crypto dogs or
they look like real dogs to me
that's a blockchain dog
oh
they just stole my identity
[Applause]
i kind of just got the feeling that we
walk into a cult i'm going to go try and
boost
some dink doing sales i need you to go
sell these to something
i was going to get in the face you're
going to get hit in the face with a lot
of cash are you a fan of nfts yeah i'm a
crypto batty duh i have some nfts you
may be interested
in uh potentially purchasing this is the
first one
it's called sensational shoe what do you
think
you don't seem like you're sold on this
can i be honest with you yeah please
it's one of the most god-ugly things
i've ever seen in my life
what is this it's blurry it's a it's a
shoe maybe the next one will be better
okay the next one is the holy grail this
is i was saving this one but um
this is called frenching fathers this is
the rarest nft that i own it's a very
sweet tender moment between garyvee and
his father um they were doing a video
together and they happened to lock lips
totally it was a touching moment so are
you interested i'm gonna have to
respectfully decline i mean have you
heard the kardashian meme
when she doesn't want to explain anymore
and she goes
abcdefg i've got to go
she stole her mic she [ __ ] on my nfts
and she [ __ ] on my name have you voted
today i have someone or ethereum i
haven't voted i'll vote though
you guys filming you got a hashtag
hashtag
dink
doing
there it is i have a question to ask you
are you familiar with this logo no but
i'm trying to get it on my blockchain
for sure this is called dink doink
what do you think of the name hot
project yeah i already want to invest
how does it make you feel when you see
it makes me feel like a dinky doing it
it makes me feel good and the amount of
fun is e you know what i mean like
in conceptual amounts of funny
that's exactly
the point that makes you cuz he looks
like a little spring he's springing up
profits only go up
history oh [ __ ] bro it's been very
elevated as you can see it's had a
little volatility it got popped on right
there yeah yeah everything went down
yeah yeah but this seems pretty stable
right yeah no but it's upside down
wait what it's upside down
okay well okay this doesn't look as
promising i mean i mean everything has
an initial like hi
it's point zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero two five i
actually don't know if anyone takes it
okay
i don't know wait where are you selling
the nft yet well you just gotta
i don't know so this is sensational shoe
oh wow oh man that's uh that's kind of
terrible i don't know it's kind of
reminds me like pooh water this is
called frenching fathers
this was a tender moment between gary
and his dad oh and i think that's just
as terrible maybe even worse i don't
even know if i would put my crumbs of
crypto in it if i told you this was the
logo of a very very
very profitable coin would you want to
invest
probably not it's [ __ ] trash
it's not like it's not that bad right no
it's a 10 out of 10. it's garbage it's a
spring with [ __ ] eyes and stick hands
put his tongue away
okay oh yeah well just as terrible
that's that's just your opinion i guess
no dude it sucks
okay
all right
how much have we made frenching fathers
tell me the total what do we got nothing
zero do you see how much garyvee was
making on this stupid like he drew a
dragonfly and made like thirty thousand
dollars
you're judging me how many people have
invested in a ding joint how many people
have you converted to okay none yet but
that's because they don't understand the
vision i am very heavily invested in big
going like a lot that's not good like a
scary amount
like it would ruin my opinion bro i
don't want to talk about it
this is not working obviously i have a
backup plan i've created a new
cryptocurrency i'd like to introduce you
to pad coin what's bad coin pad coin is
the future what is pd i don't even know
what i'm wearing okay
it it stands for pump and dump
but they don't have to know that is
there blood on your hand you've got
blood on your fingers what the [ __ ] is
that from my nose why is
you took me to is literally [ __ ]
killing me dude what are you watching
around like 11. i don't get nosebleeds
like that what the f
this is like some david cronenberg [ __ ]
look at this
do you think they could make me look
like this guy he's kind of a [ __ ]
freaking out
[Music]
i don't want to be here anymore i'm
freaking out dude i'm freaking out i'm
hearing [ __ ] in the bathroom there was
there's a there was there was a noise my
nose was bleeding i think i was poisoned
we gotta get out of here i think you
just need to go look at some board apes
or something no no no we just we need to
leave you have to calm down bro you know
what you need
the serenity zone go to the serenity
zone go in there go all right just wait
for me don't leave thank you
thank you voucher for a free pipeline
bad point you put that in and you'll
redeem uh 15 free pat coins do me a
favor and follow hd crypto
oh okay yeah yeah uh so unfortunately
pad coin doesn't have social media yet
it's very early on web 3 is all about
twitter and discord yeah yeah tick tock
so it's very it's sort of in its tadpole
days that interest you guys some free
pad coin if you want to just hold on to
that okay give you guys some free pad
coin
you get 15 free pad coins hop into the
future
excuse me can i give you guys some free
pad coin some free pad point i'll get
you 15 free pad coins hop into the
future pad padcoin
[Music]
i'm here to try and sell a new
cryptocurrency i i would hope that you
would invest and i have a lot of it i
have a lot of pad coin
and then i'm going to sell all of it but
you hold on
does that sound good it sounds like
an excellent business model yes it'll go
up it'll go to the moon and then i'll be
rich you'll be so rich it'll look like
it's like the opposite of the moon it's
like an inverted moon right now i had a
quick question because you said you're
with board ape right
well i'm a member i have a i have a logo
redesigned pretty similar to some
collection i've seen not this perfect
circular edge it looks like a board
toad good right i love it yeah see that
one i might consider investing in to be
honest okay so i've got you in for
probably let's say like half a million
let's make it a million
let's go
we're gonna be so rich i'm gonna be so
rich
you i don't know but i will be so rich
something wasn't right about that place
man no that didn't help that made it
worse that made it a lot worse so what
happens is i would like you
to invest
a lot of money okay then when you invest
right i will sell all of it oh
that's a good one you'll make money got
you i don't really know how that's solid
i'm in like one million or what are we
thinking
so uh one million dollars
okay um the way that my bank account is
okay
it's gonna it's gonna take a while so
maybe like
like five dollars yeah let's go
[Music]
holy [ __ ] i'm scared
it's the big thing it's the future what
are you doing ian this is my
welcome welcome everyone to my to pat
coin my booth pad pad coin dude this
literally says bad web it's nfts
there's no one here maybe you're scaring
them off dude people are literally like
packing up to leave i've had customers
walk by they see you they're getting
right because they're leaving they exit
and they're leaving go away lily hop to
a different pond
bad coin
bad coin
do you see what's going on behind me
it's a [ __ ] cult do you see what's
happening behind me
what the [ __ ] is going on i knew it the
minute we walked in that we [ __ ] up
let's
get okay you're on your own the thing
about pad coin that is completely
unparalleled it's a way for me to make a
lot of money
and
other people might make money i don't
know how i just i was feeling so very
inspired
what
wait i'm in the middle of a conference
i'm in the middle of a conference they
don't [ __ ] with jesus web 3.0 has been
dealing with a fork in a decentralized
environment
no no no no no what are you scaring
about this is a web 2.0 mentality
frankly what are you talking calm down i
gotta go
i've gone where i have to tell them
about the future i will leave you here
[Music]
dumbest [ __ ] i've ever seen and that's
why i'm all in this one's called
frenching fathers this is kind of
disrespectful maybe if it's in your
hands you can decide it's fate and i
could burn it yeah for the sake of
burning it i'll take this you'll buy it
yeah this is like 10 bucks right dude
you're lucky to get 10. it's a meal at
mcdonald's we'll take it you got it yeah
[Music]
[Music]
and that is the white duck and olive
branch
there's a fragmentation to his paintings
in there's a completeness come on all
the nine planets
so you're playing around the sun excuse
[Music]
yeah again what happened did we do we do
it yeah we do we the money we sold we
sold the beef you sold it how much you
sell it for 10 bucks okay we did it i
sold a million dollars worth of soda
coins
you got that in writing
see i got it on camera that's binding i
think it's not not at all it's binding
no it is but it is yeah that's where yes
yes yes yes we did it buddy we did it we
pulled it off come on buddy
[Music]
you know
with all this debate about the gp
and you now being an anft uh millionaire
why aren't you
sam it sounds like you just came up big
time
at the convention
well
i don't know i
maybe they have to approve it with their
bank it hasn't appeared in my account
yet i'm assuming they're working it out
well congratulations to a b and ian
delving into the world of nfts i see you
got a little bit lost in the sauce there
and maybe a little bit actually i was
wondering if i could give you guys a
couple i have a couple coupons
oh
is this the pad point yeah oh great yeah
i've been looking for that
[Applause]
let's have a look thank you what an
exclusive offer
oh wow thank you yeah
let's see it says go to url pad coin dot
me
to redeem and use code nft expo pad i
guess i'll do that right now i don't
want
i don't want anyone to beat me to it
right ian
yeah uh the offer is very limited
you want to get in on that quick all
right let me go to
pad coin
dot me
yes and redeem the code wow
the number of pad coin sales keep rising
by the minute we handed these out
all over the festival or the
expo
you've consulted on 6.4 million projects
wow yeah how did you have time to do all
that
well i i wasn't i wasn't goofing around
you know i wasn't
i wasn't hopping mad one would say
this is the future
right so go ahead and yeah just redeem
that nft expo pad yeah you're probably
gonna want to full screen this by the
way yeah so you can see all your coins
here we go it's exciting
thank you ian by the way i appreciate
getting on the ground floor of this yeah
we crashed the website it's a fantastic
opportunity i think
did we doing this live maybe a mistake
no no no this website can't crash just
refresh real quick
yeah i gave love a lot of pad coins to
make this website if i refresh it's
definitely not gonna work oh my god
oh no your project is
okay is on the ropes dude hold on hold
on
no no this can't be true okay here it
loaded it loaded
there it loaded
did it work
we crashed yeah it's crazy
everybody stop going to pad coin
trying to do a gag here
no more pad coin with peace and love
thank you thank you
this cost me a fortune in pad coins to
make this website so
guys you're [ __ ] this up for me
this is my one opportunity to get on the
ground floor pad coin you are [ __ ] it
up
well you got a shirt at least i got a
shirt
but be honest did i pay for this shirt
ian
um yes
but it's an investment it yeah for sure
um great logo do we can we possibly
throw this up on in vmix
this uh
landing page try now it just loaded for
me it did
ladies and gentlemen
yes sir
so hot the website don't load the
traffic is unbelievable it's a mad rush
[Music]
going up
ladies and gentlemen looks like we might
have to do some repairs
okay
[Music]
well the project's a success although
what was the scenario is struggling
uh ian what was the serenity room
um
yeah they have that set up there i think
it might be you know
when you invest in a project and you put
your life savings in it and then you
check your phone uh-oh
it's down 99
you'd want to go to the serenity room
and maybe you know calm down it just
looked like a cubicle with a chair
well you know oh look it loaded oh go
ahead
[Music]
[Laughter]
pump and dump
why don't you web 3d appearance
you're a [ __ ] idiot
take it from me one of the founders of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] silly zonka you
just got f a on saturday
oh my god what is that
so [ __ ] stupid and sorry
[Laughter]
i'm gonna
you're a [ __ ] idiot
[Music]
wait so
wait hold on
been deposited directly into your uh
into your blockchain not zach not the
zilli zonk i wonder if anyone from the
convention is it possible someone from
convention actually went to that and
tried to redeem it i mean we
[Laughter]
i was actually tracking the traffic and
we had a lot a lot of traffic actually
yeah really really
do you know if anyone went to the zilli
zonk landing page yeah a couple yes
actually well i don't know the team
looks pretty reputable um yeah here's
the the leadership jordan peterson
no that's uh
[Laughter]
lovebot and carlos gatos
my williams still don't believe in me
a super successful person you can see
this wow
right you can see the transaction rates
above two it's kind of interesting let's
take a look here
so one d's
bro you can't tell me to read something
i said i mean come on
well read the read the one furthest to
the right then okay uh
j is that a j g m a
it's covered up a little bit i think the
first letter might be an s i'm just
specific you can see it all right
yes
oh
no
i can't believe you've done this
i'm sorry i did
you know i was actually trying to
establish a real i paid love uh and zack
i'm kind of
kind of disappointed this was meant to
be my new project so get zonked [ __ ]
well sorry to everyone who's excited to
get in on the ground floor of pad it
turned out it was just a giant scam yeah
can't believe it by ian and zach so that
pad coin for the dink joint cover i did
is that that's not going to work yo i
want to hear that again that was so fun
do you guys just have that
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
shred it up
[Music]
in my face
[Music]
[Music]
my girlfriend says
[Music]
we gotta upload this to uh our
highlights channel
damn
shredding the [ __ ] out of that
[Music]
okay there we go thanks thank you i
wasn't ready for a whole nother verse
[Laughter]
sounded good though thank you
i mean it sounded great yeah that was
awesome thank you thank you i said to
zach before the show i think he might
even
it might even be catcher than the
original i know that's a huge flame
but it's been stuck in my head
well it could be is it maybe you could
release that on your upcoming album yeah
that could be secret tracker
i have a show uh coming up so maybe i'll
open with that
that would tear the house yeah i know
well
good job guys yeah that was awesome
what was the vibe like there though was
it really just a bunch of suckers
um it wasn't uh
it wasn't as funny
as i guess we expected there weren't
that many characters it was really just
kind of a bunch of
just dudes in a room
just vibing out
but not
not over the top i don't know i think
maybe there was a weird air
above the convention due to recent uh
you know
circumstance crash yeah
yeah i thought it was pretty funny how
these guys were looking at the nfts you
made which
were spitting [ __ ] carbon copies of
garyvee's nfts
i mean you cannot distinguish that shoe
from anything he's drawn and they're
like this is dog [ __ ] this [ __ ] sucks
yeah i mean i think people knew we were
kind of goofing around and messing
around so so were you actually able to
sell the intimate uh tender kiss
no sales on the frenching fathers
still out there
this is all right it's not fair i know
well good job guys
oh what happened to the jimmy leaf fan
meetup
uh do you want me to get him on the line
i mean so jimmy was gonna do a fan
meetup at two
which is [ __ ] hilarious in atlantic
city and i was so sure nobody would show
up or maybe like one person i don't know
i wanted to have him report live from
the fan meetup okay
um here's some of his posts about it
he's been hyping this up eh
jimmy lee fanfare in atlantic city this
friday deep fried meme
man the guy doing his post is a [ __ ]
menace
where are you gonna be
bad boy
bad boy jimmy lee live at atlantic city
wait does he say where to meet him
nope
he's just a generic serious somewhere in
atlantic city
is fan
fair of place
because he says bad boy thank you that
boy jimmy lee atlantic city friday at
fan or jesus fanfare
the thing about jimmy lee on the streets
is
it's not hard to find him you know true
you're gonna run into him eventually
whether you like it or not
all right well let's let's get him on
the line i just i want to know how his
dave's been going
if he's running to any fans
yeah
what jimmy went after arab world news
yeah and he made a camel joke we're all
coming to an actual egyptian so [ __ ]
oh god i'm so sick of it that [ __ ] how
dare yeah arab world news is like
an angel we're not worthy of him
where's his camel at shut up
how dare you
he really learns nothing yeah i'm
[ __ ] mega over jimmy i'm not i'm just
gonna be perfectly honest
right i was just captivated by the idea
of a fan meetup for him
i it is a problem that he does not learn
it's quite unfortunate
all right well as as we get them on the
line
i don't know if you saw this gila but
milk boys
um
[Music]
elon musk right
i saw the announcement i didn't watch
anything
which is pretty incredible that's a huge
gap yeah
i mean
and such an array of topics that you
could
uh
thank you
yeah i just want that one clip
here
it's such an array of topics you could
talk about i mean elon musk you could
talk about
technology electric vehicles
allegations
massages
horses horses horse [ __ ]
baby [ __ ] yeah piss my ass
well now boys you know
they really didn't waste the opportunity
to
have this incredible dialogue with elon
musk ladies and gentlemen
feast your eyes
do you play video games
yeah a game
i just played eldon ring which is really
great elton green yeah alvin ring i
haven't even heard of that have you guys
elder ringer amazing wait what uh
console i play pc
really yeah what's the game i'm sorry i
haven't
heard a great game uh it's probably game
of the year
um
let me get roasted by the gaming
community oh yeah you're screwed it's a
problem
it's a from software yeah anyway um it's
like a shooter or
it's like a
fantasy what
game
uh
it's awesome game i highly recommend
playing old marine well now i'm gonna
play it i promise you that's great sick
um fellaini has the most beautiful art
i've ever seen sick
[ __ ] advanced
it's just beautiful art
artistically
amazing did you grow up playing like
video games
yeah i grew up playing very primitive
video games
do you play video games what a [ __ ]
wow
i mean these guys did not waste an
opportunity high level discussion why
are you gonna ask about video games if
you don't know anything about video
games also like he's the way he's asking
elon musk
to explain what this game is like it's
like even i know the man has so much to
talk about
you could ask him he like how dumb elon
musk i feel like you could see like why
am i here i'm explaining what elden ring
is like no no shoddys or anything
you play video games really really you
play that on the computer put on
astroworld
so what kind of game is it
crazy that was so weird
i was just flabbergasted i saw that on
tick-tock
and it wasn't even packaged like look
how [ __ ] these guys are at podcasting
there it was like that you saw
yeah this one it was like elon musk
talks about elden ring
and i could not [ __ ] believe that
this is our competition ladies and
gentlemen
now boys
i'm gonna go rip a dart
[Music]
these this is the high level [ __ ] right
here my friends
i hate the way they were sitting too
it's like
do you play video games it's like you
just give up like yeah
what what do you play it on
dude pc
it's giving me like what you're stuck
alone in the room with like your
girlfriend's younger brother
well she's in the bathroom except it's
elon musk the richest man in the world
who has like a billion interesting
things you can ask him yeah i know yeah
21 21 savage is basically like my spirit
animal and [ __ ]
and elk boys ladies and gentlemen
who is this goon by the way
look i don't like elon musk for but but
like in terms of having a conversation
this man should not even be in the same
building as him
this man should be like taking out the
trash or something
cleaning toilets
loading up not that there's anything
wrong with that of course loading up the
cars for everybody else yeah boys and
cars
rip agar my guy
how did they come together like what the
milk boys or how did they get you they
get these massive guests and i don't
understand it dude
like what the [ __ ] bro where's our
guests well they theoretically have a
big audience
yeah well yeah they do when they get
like mike tyson and elon musk and [ __ ]
come on
uh nelk boys podcast like take a look at
this [ __ ]
now granted i haven't watched really a
full episode i don't know if this is
reflective of
everything that goes on there
nine million views i mean what the
that's like an easy dub though elon musk
yeah i guess that's the advantage of not
talking [ __ ] about everybody mm-hmm
maybe it would be possible if i was
what can i do though the guy [ __ ]
sucks
andrew tate
mark cuban
why
it's very like bro
bro club just from looking at the
thumbnails oh yeah
post malone was on there
shout out
um
i don't know man do they have like good
look [ __ ] caitlyn jenner like explain
that one
candace always explain caitlyn jenner to
me
right now
who's booking there who's booking their
[ __ ] dude
jamie foxx
explain that
don't make any sense
khabib
well they're tight like with dana white
so any like ufc dude they
that one okay i'll get that one but like
mike tyson
[ __ ] dude i'd love to talk to mike tyson
am i just bitter and jealous hater i
just don't understand how they get this
mike tyson talks about dmt 9 million
views
come on
i feel like the crazy guess started with
donald trump
i think they've just been riding a wave
after that using him as an example
right
donald trump jr [ __ ] who would
have that idiot on even if he's famous
like you know donald trump jr doesn't
have a single
original or interesting thought in his
head talk to you soon
yeah it's just not fair
this is not fair i don't know what to
say
they get elon musk
and they ask this [ __ ]
am i just being a hater ass [ __ ] i
don't know yeah
and also
almost everybody that you just listed
doesn't sound like anybody that these
are all people that you consistent you
you are currently selling a t-shirt yeah
with devil horns drawn on elon musk
right right right i'm not really sure
why
uh
yeah it's a very specific crowd let's
say mike tyson i would love to have one
i haven't said a single bad word about
mike tyler all right i'll reach out
come on get mike get me mike [ __ ] you
that was a piece of [ __ ]
but let's just take let's just um take
in this beautiful moment here one more
time i just played elden ring yeah
elton green alvin ring i haven't even
heard of that
i play pc
really yeah what's the game really sorry
really elden ring is uh is it a computer
uh it's probably game of the year
um
let me get roasted by the giving
community oh yeah you're screwed it's a
problem
it's a from software yeah anyway um it's
like a shooter or
like a shooter this is this is the
dumbest conversation i've ever seen it's
a full send right there
you're actually being a half center
right now dude he's just he's just on a
different plane of existence
as them
i feel like me and elon would we have a
lot in common game wise i'm on i'm
following every word he's saying you're
better than he is at it you're way
better at eldering than him
i'm going to send it
anyway can you imagine how much he's
worth like every minute he's sitting
there it's like multiple millions
he's like just being talking with these
low low i don't know
like
barely functional iq brain waves
yeah you play you play games bro
he lost like 50 million sitting there
that's so true probably even more than
that honestly
yeah
bro you play video games
is it like a shooter what's elder ring
do you play it on xbox or playstation
[ __ ] this is not good
is it a shooter like
it's a safe space for [ __ ] well said
olivia
yeah exactly
well said
it's true
the interviewers don't push back so it's
like a right a beautiful melting pot of
horrible opinion
yeah
and and elk news this other guy steve
will do it his channel got permanently
banned by youtube
like last week
and this is the guy who's like in deep
deep deep with steak
and if you ask me
the reason he got permanently banned is
because he was promoting gambling on
youtube which you're not you're not
allowed to do that like on twitch
they have a strict policy against that
[ __ ] so
it says we've reviewed your content and
found severe repeated violations and we
just straight outright erased your [ __ ]
so
i think it's the
steak stuff so i hope it was worth it
dude
get that steak money because they don't
give a [ __ ] about you i guarantee that
they'd be like [ __ ] sorry your channel
got erased well anyway see you later
of course the con the uh support for
steve will do it is a
who's who of
of h3 villains [ __ ] trump jr riding
for
stevo stevie
total [ __ ] says donald trump jr
without any
information about why he was banned
good luck with all of that
wait who's oh kyle's of course the other
no yeah the no [ __ ] up
bradley what the strong support strong
what the what the [ __ ] up
you know what this is like his homie
yeah yeah well he brought steve into the
crew because kyle's like the og i feel
like he could make a stronger statement
than that right [ __ ] up [ __ ] [ __ ] up
anyways
wait i read that
i read that this is all he ever said
about it kyle uh they talked about in
the elon interview actually
he didn't like tweet about it or
really show any outwards
until until they talked about on the
elon interview i believe that reply on
instagram was the extent of his that's a
commentary on it [ __ ] that probably
probably because he knows the reason so
he knows if he comes out he can't be
defending it right right
that's very true right what the and then
this guy is also a knock so he doesn't
say [ __ ] either he just goes what the
dan blizzarian wow
[ __ ] youtube the very own um
original red pill [ __ ] boy dan
blizzarian
[ __ ] youtube he says
[Applause]
fascinating
adam 22 with the wtf why are you
bothering to leave a comment if just to
say wtf like
low effort i i don't get it
uh jason nash actually had a strong
opinion
i was
i this made me
less enthused to talk to him i'll be
honest just one comment alone i was like
i'm not losing
interest in the nash
by the way i saw a lot of people angry
at me for
[Music]
even the suggestion
that i would have jason on the podcast
i understand the seth i didn't forget
about the seth essay stuff i do think
the whole thing would be obviously i
would ask him about all that you know
but he's jason said i'm confused
don't you just help people on your
channel and give them money makes no
sense jason what the [ __ ] what's the
last time you watched his videos
he literally you know how he pays for
that [ __ ]
crypto unregulated gambling mr jason
match who's unplugged wait who's that
is that fit and fresh yeah that's fit
you'll be back they can't stop you this
one's from oj simpson he says man they
they really took your head off with the
youtube really took your head off
yeah this one's from
bill cosby
says
wish you the best brother
have a jello
in the meantime
fresh
a fresh fit something gonna work out bro
love the optimism
nice group of people
actually really supportive
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] up man is my favorite though damn
bro that's that's like his best friend
my favorite is what the what the hell
what the
wtf what the
what the
can you imagine my youtube channel gets
banned i lose all we all lose our jobs
what
and then like uh
let's hit him with that alright who's
our youtube bestie at this moment
know like the sun yeah you just go what
the that's the extent of his commentary
on it
ethan got banned what the what
yeah
love that for them
all right do you want to talk to jimmy
lee bring him on we'll make it fast guys
don't worry we'll keep keep on shortly
share
artistic okay
jimmy is we're seeing the side of a
building
oh i'm kind of scaffolding
okay
what oh wow look at that
that was a good
entrance i love that hold it guys guys
guys
hold on
[Music]
put the new glasses on
jimmy is calling in from his atlantic
city fan meetup
he called her fanfare
and i just he looks like he's at a hotel
pool not a great place to come
i think you forgot to flip it who's that
wait is it the beach
shaving that way how do you flip it
are these just patrons or oh those are
those are our employees
they're all employed
big fans worth the hard rock beats
in atlantic city morning's
is their workplace even okay with this
zach used to run with them
we got a security guard abraham
lincoln's younger brother
what
oh my god
should we just bail on this because he's
not going to let me get a word in for
he's been decent much going on the
outlaws here so jimmy i just wanted to
check in he's got to get away from the
music on the fan meet up let me lower
the music hold on oh my god it's you're
not the only person there all over again
hold on we're going to cut the music
jimmy you know
the restaurants
what's his name what's your name
my name is bill do you have any idea who
jimmy lee is
no
cool run
get away fast
he's a fan he heard some really corny
jokes
get away fast my friend yeah apparently
i'm gay
oh my god okay
zach you're gonna get along with him
perfect i think we gotta cut it all
right thanks jimmy thanks jamie have fun
is that it
i think so well i just wanted to know
how your fans cut the jersey out i just
wanted to know how the fan meetup is
going but it doesn't seem that they even
know who you are well it was medium
today it wasn't as big as i wanted i'm
not gonna lie well medium implies that
anyone was there was there anyone well
we had ian who's a big tick tocker we
ran into him he's a fan i'm a fan we
reminded the bruno mars who who's uh
who's appearing at the hard rock we got
a picture with him and now we're at the
beach for so it was a handful it wasn't
as many as we anticipated and bobby's
here
he's a big tick tocker from uh
new jersey
jimmy told me he hired security for this
did you hire security jimmy for this fan
meetup we hired security and he got
stuck in traffic on the expressway
and that's the truth
can i ask you a question
i looked over your posts to announce the
fan meetup i don't think you ever said
an address could that be a problem
no i said atlantic city
what that's not a specific city
uh next time i need specifics i think
you're right yeah atlantic city
how is it my fault because you're my
promoter you didn't tell me no i do not
condone anything you do yeah
you know you know to help me so honestly
it was okay today it wasn't as much as
we thought
right that's okay bruno mars showed up
that is awesome i'm being honest with
you
what the hell ethan
i sent you five t-shirts yesterday
jimmy
it's a city of half a million how do you
expect people to find you
i don't know i wasn't using my noodle
no no
i have histrionic personality disorder i
forgot
right right right
hey
dan you're getting your shirts next week
i even got one for dan who hates me
i really do you're an [ __ ] oh
don't say that i know and i'm all right
with it dan it took me a while to accept
it okay good
glad you know come on
georgie outlaw loves h3h3
all right all right cool all right well
how what what so you're out there on
vacation what are you just having a good
time uh we're here with uh dr greg and
me and we're having some dinner we're
going down to himalino in a bit of a
little while
and we're just relaxing today we're on
the boardwalk to have a big uh
country music festival so we came down
cause we figured to be busy and it is
very busy but a lot of people going to
the concert
right cool
so
well it is what it is
it sure is all right jimmy well you take
care okay
you have a fun time hey say hi say hi to
gary klein
i certainly will and make sure that you
bring security when you go to that
concert i don't want you to get mobbed
all right and uh i love your support
love you guys and i appreciate it when
you get your shirts reach out to me let
me know you have them okay all right
thank you okay all right we'll be
looking i love you all right love you
too jimmy
all right
so
there it is
jimmy out in atlanta i'm not worthy than
we even anticipated yeah now
did the guy say that he made a gay joke
about him yeah yeah just like of course
i'm out i'm out he goes apparently i'm
gay
it's an old-timey joke and then he goes
he likes all the time he's an old-school
joke he goes you'll get along with him
great zack yeah he he that's his shtick
he's like zach you're gay he just keeps
calling me gay yeah
do you think maybe you're arab you got a
camel
it's really a shame it's just a shame
look he has histrionic personality
disorder at the end of the day
i guess he does
i have a question do you guys really
think he
went there with security for a fan
meetup and never said the address
yeah i think so
that
he said uh what was atlantic city three
to six
he's there
come find me
real jimmy i mean the man is a working
dentist i think he got the the idea
because apparently last weekend he went
to atlantic city and he did run into
some fans of the show oh you know what i
think maybe you thought he would just
run into people right i know what he was
thinking
he's so famous
that the whole of atlanta city will be
on the lookout for jimmy lee right
people will be shouting out of their
windows running down after him cars will
be pulling over
and that's why he brought the security
because he expected pandemonium i heard
that uh he didn't even want to send us
t-shirts at first yeah we had to bend
his arm for the t-shirts he said he said
he's gonna hook us up with t-shirts at
first and then we all gave him our sizes
and then zach was asking him hey where's
the t-shirt at jimmy and then he said
work with me
and then he's like what did he say zach
he couldn't afford the shirts at the end
of this no it was
he i i forgot what it was exactly but it
was something he didn't want to he
didn't want to send him
because he has to buy the shirts he
didn't want to buy us the shirts this
dude drives a rolls-royce and owns like
five dentistry offices and all the
shirts are like they won't send us a
[ __ ] shirt don't
exactly it's all using my ip yeah he
uses my [ __ ] picture in his instagram
posts oh yeah i [ __ ] despise the man
jim oh come on dan you you're too hard
on the man i'm not too hard he's a softy
he has histrionic personalities he's not
a sophomore he's not a software he uses
that as a defense he's a problem you're
an ableist dan you're being ableist
right now he's gonna problem is not
learning like we keep telling him this
joke is racist this joke is offensive
you know like but it's old testament to
it and then it goes and does it again
and again well that is the problem i
hear he's going to be in europe tomorrow
from four to eight
so you know off the phone
for realize
yeah people i see someone asking why are
you so attached to jimmy i don't know
you know we have so much history
together and
i just got a soft spot for the guy i was
happy to have you wanted him to succeed
you know we wanted this to be a success
story when he's dr james he r he is wait
hold on sorry is it 3 15 uh it's a pride
minute guys
we gotta we gotta
3 15 is pride minute
for the month of august
now is the time if you want to express
pride in
lgbtq plus
if you want to
be proud of who you are express yourself
uh this is your minute
so
enjoy it
as you know
uh
ben shapiro i believe it was who said
what's with pride month pride day
another pride hour right
it did yeah yeah that's that's where the
pride minute comes from it was jordan
peterson i was jordan peter is someone
actually timing this because we don't
i don't go over i think
we're already over it probably
um
well it's 3 16. it is 3 16. okay stop
stop stop
stop now [ __ ] stop being proud of
being gay that was my favorite one we've
done so far yeah yeah it felt if it was
you felt that yeah we'll stop the
minute's over
it's over
feel ashamed again sinners
oh my god what i missed this whole thing
it was funny yeah pride minute
i i think with the the thing with jimmy
is when he's out of character he really
is a nice guy mm-hmm yes he really is
yeah that's why it's hard but when he
goes and you know dr jekyll and mr hyde
type [ __ ] he totally
he goes off the rockers and you're right
he will not change yeah we've tried so
many times everything it's just look i
think we we've tried there was a
redemption arc everyone was loving when
we got his background and stuff if we
want to if we want to enjoy jimmy from
now on it needs to be in small
controlled doses
and we need to accept that the man is
not going to change like our dads and
grandpas you know
they just who they are
okay
shout out to me lee atlanta city eat
your heart out and that's that
that's so [ __ ] awesome though
three to six
it is very funny that he just named an
entire city we should do that sometime
h3 fan meet up this weekend guys here in
l.a we'll see you there keep your eyes
peeled
los angeles six to ten everything made
up in l.a i mean
[Laughter]
we're gonna be on the uh
heads up california
we're gonna be on the continent of south
america from four to ten
heads up
people of california i will be somewhere
in your state from three to six
oh that's funny man that's really
something
[Laughter]
yeah oh my god
so anyway um should we get into radish
head because this [ __ ] is so interesting
yeah we've been putting it on for a
couple weeks now oh also trailers
ripping off black craters but i think
it's too late in the day for all that
either you're going to love this
i found this on tick tock
and it absolutely blew
my [ __ ] mind okay there's a group of
like
russian i would say like uh i would call
them daredevils but it's actually
they're more like
psychopaths
lunatics
yeah all of those but they have like no
they have no worldly
fear of dying
and so
they go on these
adventures
and the one i saw of them was them
swimming in the waters of trino
chernobyl react like
really nuclear plant
and their skin was like turning green
and [ __ ] and i was like what what and
the hell is this so we did research this
guy named turnip head is the king is the
head of the group
have you ever seen someone listen and
i'm telling you man this
is so nuts
and we try to do it more of a deep uh
research into this and
we weren't able to turn up much maybe
you guys know more about it
oh hearing he's from he's a massive
youtuber no yeah no we found his channel
yeah oh
he's a massive youtuber
like four hundred thousand subs for
fifty thousand maybe not massive but it
a large uh youtuber yes okay so never
mind
yeah here's his channel
uh
this man
goes to chernobyl
like he's going to play in the snow
uh
so here's the clip that i found
check this [ __ ] out for death like this
the foreign guys broke into the
chernobyl exclusion zone this music
gonna get me claimed or what this is
we've watched this music a million times
because this is the no such thing as a
coincidence
soak in radioactive nuclear wastewater
enjoy happy adequate absorption of
radiation nutrients the leader is called
radish head a top player who has been
wandering around i love like all
everything in this narration for many
years by a little bit some excitement
and he comes to the chernobyl nuclear
power plant built in the former soviet
union this place has long been listed as
a forbidden area for life friends who
have seen the movie know the chernobyl
nuclear explosion was one of the worst
nuclear accidents in human history it is
400 times more radioactive than the
atomic bomb of hiroshima in a decade 170
000 people died in the vicinity and the
radish head that is not afraid of death
is about to break into here he took his
favorite friends to see the secrets that
were not known just arrived here
radiation values have been measured a
few kilometers from the site of the
accident it's already within the
radiation range our radish heads have
always been lucky a lot of blessing he
was not afraid of these small radiations
at all he quickly assembled to find
death the foursome swung wildly toward
the penalty area not a single creature
could be seen within a few kilometers of
radius there was a dead silence ordinary
people who have no mental problems will
never come here this dude said that when
the
the brothers quickly ran down the stairs
just came to the ground the official
expedition has not yet begun the
long-haired brother felt the radiation
the body consciously sweats and is
physically weak neither one test at this
time the radiation has soared to more
than 500 radish head comforted him but
definitely hold on the excitement is
still inside a long-lost smile appeared
on his face
it seems that the strength of the soviet
union at that time was absolutely very
powerful it's all big discarded tin cans
measured the sand on the ground the
radiation value is still more than 500
this sand can come in a lot at that time
the nuclear explosion was born the air
force urgently airlifted mountains of
sand to extinguish the fire now they
remain here forever the bald brother sat
on the radiation turn it looks very
comfortable soon they found the stairs
the further inside you go i watched it
by the way i just found this on my feet
and i watched this whole thing
with my mouth wide [ __ ] open like
they react to the footage
everything it was so captivating i just
it's unbelievable but there's a whole
series of these right there's like three
of these bizarrely narrated ones well
yeah and make sure you have those queued
up because i want to watch all three of
them
so the other ones uh were removed from
tick tock oh
probably
but we have from their channel
um videos of them in the water all of
these tick tocks are people just ripping
off these guys content this is this is
not original
the brother with the long hair you have
to be mentally insane to come the man
with the head that's shaped like the
radish
he showed his long-lost smile
literally amazing he smiled for the
first time
yeah but i just wanted to put you guys
in the zone where i found this video and
then we'll go to the to the photo yeah
more eerie there are still 1986 warning
signs left in the room at this time the
long-haired brother could not hold on
already in a trance the whole person is
going to collapse radioactive sweat was
bubbling up on the nose they hurry
number 96 volt pressurized shock the
radish head also came up and took a sip
today's radish head is very well behaved
don't dare to run around
he was afraid of getting lost with his
friends all the scrap iron here is
rotten that's when someone asked why not
tear down here to sell iron of course
not the objects here basically contain a
lot of radioactive dust once demolished
this dust will once again pollute the
surrounding air speaking of radish heads
found a cellar it's all green water
inside isn't this heaven
then the radish head will take everyone
inside to play look everywhere for the
entrance soon they found another
abandoned railway the long-haired
brother has now become insane
[Music]
everyone gave the long-haired brother a
test 106 degrees measured the radiation
value for him this dude now has its own
radiation
[Laughter]
well i found the entrance to the cellar
it was filled with liquids of unknown
elements a few people decided to go down
and play something exciting they lifted
the kayak away nothing protected they
can drive a boat directly in the water
they explore the deepest part of the
earth others were at least still in
rowing boats and didn't dare to get wet
and the radish head stood directly in
the water
it's just that this leg is a little
extra cold it was truly a full fledged
heel that's what i was saying this video
is [ __ ] in
his thing his leg is a little extra cold
i've never seen anything like this these
men yeah are going swimming in
radioactive chernobyl water like
is that like dangerous afterwards to
anyone they're gonna be in contact with
probably yeah because their body is
going to be radioactive now yeah
well if any like um dust that's on them
would potentially be hazardous but if
they get washed off
they wouldn't be well they're breathing
it they're they're in it i mean their
body
i'm
not totally convinced that they're not
faking it faking what they're there
their location they're definitely at
chernobyl you could tell from the
outside 100
yeah but yeah i mean the footage inside
the inside yeah i mean that could just
be some industrial place i don't know
that's radish head bro why are you
questioning it's not integrity it's
turnip head those names turn up heads
sorry are those names just by the
narrator that's not actually i think so
um the actual the actual dude is named
super sauce yeah exactly yeah
the whole
tick tock version of this wow wouldn't
trust
dude the narrator is so epic turnip head
who thinks of that it's so weird
um and a correction before when we said
their channel has 400 000 subs that is
actually they have a a
sub channel where they dub things into
english their main channel has five
millions and it's in russian so uh i
think ukrainian i don't think they're
russian yeah you're crazy so based on
what you guys look does it look like it
would be fake or real dude it's real
i mean these guys are the real deal it's
definitely wilder if we just
go along wait no i want to finish this
okay okay okay i'm loving jumping ahead
but
this is an odyssey
look they definitely went to chernobyl
that much i don't question i saw him in
front they're 100 percent there
but it's true that you could fake these
shots that could be something else
radish wouldn't do that he's a real g
this is his whole shtick yeah move
forward what unknown creatures await
them
you think he was born looking like that
no
but they're gonna get like from
exploring cancer in two days after that
no
no
i mean
no probably not to it could take a few a
few years yeah
i mean
they're not guaranteed to get cancer
they get lucky
but most likely within 10 years yeah
yeah very very very tourists in there
that you can go on yeah i mean you can
visit the trano there
the radiation varies significantly from
like room to room even um
i've seen documentaries where people go
and like it's they'll be walking down a
hall and it's like don't turn that
corner or you'll get radiation poisoning
like almost immediately
[Music]
have you ever seen someone all right so
yeah wow all right i think tick tock
must have removed the other ones because
it was just two nuts yeah
but okay so let me pull up
oh uh like back in the day like a in old
russia there was that uh nuke uh nuclear
plant that blew up like what's the name
of that
you know what i'm talking about right
or something
[Laughter]
right on buddy
uh so it's called straight out of ebola
if you explore under the chernobyl
reactor we are looking for hot pieces
impripiac
he's cutting his wrath with a [ __ ]
chainsaw
oh my god
i love that he's wearing a suit
yeah turnip head always looking dapper
[Music]
oh my god oh my god armenia
he just threw a [ __ ] chainsaw towards
him all right after seeing that maybe
they are in general
i'm saying these guys are these guys
don't give a [ __ ] could have died so
quick oh boy like they're just giggling
having a good old time [ __ ]
threw a active chainsaw they're like the
ukrainian jackass
pretty accurate actually yeah
yeah i think this is more hardcore than
dragons well it is ukrainian
this is giving me like pain olympics
vibes
the way these guys don't care about
their lives
he gives it back to them after they
threw it to him
where's my ukulele it's over there on
the boat
diva hold
i'll take my guitar
please hold it
i'll give you 50. i'm so glad they did a
dub channel
give it back please
forgive you for everything with this
content
have you guys lost that
if i've learned anything from playing
half half-life it's or no fallout it's
don't go in the water
right
here's the most watched part let's see
what happens here we have been here for
12 hours and having a great time this is
a very unique place
alex what are these sounds
this is from the boat error is coming
out while this camera is driving me
crazy now i'll discipline him we'll
arrange a disciplinary battalion for him
now by the way can he swim
we drank radioactive water
hey
what are they doing
come right
you'll be in trouble now why are you
throwing stones what kind of jokes are
this i came with a guitar i'm an art
lover
what are you talking about are crazy
nobody's watching us here you can do a
sin as they say
oh wait are we watching the same party
yeah yeah wow
the vlog squad's looking rough
and they really had to step it up
so that was one here it continues uh
stalkers penetrate
in a scuba under chernobyl power unit
and they fall into radioactive water
oh yeah i saw this one on tick tock get
a load of this
they strap him up yup
and some do-it-yourself
snorkeling gear
[Laughter]
how's the water
not too cold
we didn't think about measuring the
radiation here
walk slowly and go down
see guys there are steps to minus one
more flow
well now sir squat down a bit
something tells me that it's not
airtight that much
oh it's good
it's got uh some duct tape belt
no gloves no gloves necessary
i feel like that would just choke him
take your time let's see slowly fill in
the water again don't worry
everything works
[Music]
oh my gosh look at that
isn't just a glass thing
it's just like an aquarium or something
it works come on put the camera on him
dude they're at chernobyl
i have no doubt i the more i the more
convinced i am
he's actually under the water man he
actually is going for it
it's waterproof and shoots really well
under the water
it's so cool it must be an amazing
feeling underwater there it can be
compared to anything you just need to
fill it
[Music]
this is so
the crazy really cold guys here's the
most replayed part right here come rod
bomb the ear his life depends on you
okay i'm pumping it he's pumping in air
for him i love how they're worried that
the water is really cold i think that's
what they're worried about oh he's
pumping in water into his helmet i think
what is going on
[Music]
this is the most watched part so i won't
see
what goes down here so that's it
here he is coming out your helmet don't
tilt your head forward the water will
not end or tilt your head back so that
the water flows out
help remove the bowl
this man has definitely drank in
radioactive water
the scotch tape came off and the
structure broke
so look remove the top part from it and
hold it under water somewhere at one
meter if something goes wrong then just
throw it away
just keep it under water forever
[Applause]
this guys
oh there this is a turnip head my man
are you ready to pump it up come on do
it i'm ready careful what's his actual
name
i like that
what's his name
oh no love loved it super
yeah
wait what are you serious
yeah it's a huge meme within my like
friend group we always watch these guys
why didn't you say anything yeah we were
looking for the channel i just we're
looking for this
i've been giving you a scene for all
along i said there's no youtubers no no
when we were writing this up how did why
didn't you say anything
i don't know what you guys are writing
up until i read the doc
we were talking about it in the group i
was like check out this crazy [ __ ] what
is it
and you're a fan the whole damn time
is this the craziest thing you've seen
them do sometimes i miss the shackles i
wake up later yeah
this is one of the craziest things they
do but they they're like doing this [ __ ]
all the time
let's see what the here's um their other
part
found a flooded bunker these guys
actually under chernobyl reactors
well love based on your knowledge of
them it's probably real right what do
you think i know for a fact they have
done things in chernobyl obviously i
don't know exactly that place and
but
they always have these like what's it
called the measure uh
[Music]
radioactivity yeah gag encounter and
it's like
always like going to the max i don't
know they didn't use it in this video
though so that might be a little bit
suspicious i don't know
well here they are i mean they're
clearly in chernobyl
ain't nowhere else in the world that
looks like that
right that is definitely yeah
we mustn't make noise
this is the tractor and it's right about
here
come on put it on quickly
it's been a year since we were here yes
the first time nobody knew that you
shouldn't die with a gas mask this wall
was blocked and it was impossible
that's my boy now
radish head ladies and gentlemen
actually one more
oh here they actually do they get a
professional scuba gear
this guy for some reason gets the real
scuba [ __ ]
right let's go
wait turn on the oxygen supply
don't forget that turned on
almost
wait a bit don't open too much may burst
we don't need it should i open to the
end yeah
good luck
this is insane i've never seen this holy
moly
i mean i don't know what you expect to
find down there yeah it's just a flooded
concrete room stairwell he's moving on
yes straight down look even the light
has changed
now the lantern has become bright green
he went on the light was gone
oh my god
these people are so insane
this is giving me anxiety
somewhere gurgles i hear
wait what happened
yeah
are you crazy are you anymore don't they
know this we're like godzilla what's the
matter what's up with him
wait something has surfaced need to get
it out sooner oh my gosh
need to do something urgently
where did you run where is he
he's on the other side this is gotta be
a bit right what happened
where is he guys
vlad
where is he oh no where what will we do
it's definitely spread through the ice
they do that sometimes
all right well there you have it i don't
know what the [ __ ] that was but now you
guys have to watch it
interesting pretty interesting right i
mean
oh
i've never seen anything like that
they're doing like a war content now in
ukraine it's kind of weird
like
going to the russians and [ __ ] like that
they say
yeah they're like making youtube videos
on the front line or or they're like
yeah
wow interesting
does it seem dangerous
i'm sending you a link
okay here we go
radish head on the front line read the
title
the title is we found the bunker where
the sergeant russian soldiers were
hiding didn't help
but i didn't uh shake this video before
so just know
let's see there might be some weird
stuff
here's the most played
there you have it though
they're out there
but not for long
enjoy it while you can love
these guys
gonna be hitting an expiration date here
pretty soon
um that's about all i've got what do you
guys think
about radish head or just just in
general
uh what do i think what else you know
hmm
you don't even have to think about it
dude
oh i keep putting off the addison
reverse
addison ray's dad
tana versus
hannah yeah
that man is so embarrassing holy [ __ ] no
addison is really
conducting herself very well and
i mean i haven't really been following
the story but i see things come up here
and there can you imagine i don't know
oh my god her dad
is trying to be like a social media
influencer
and he's trying to get people to fight
him and stuff
and the [ __ ] he's putting out man
check this out
he's trying to fight young gravy
this is the video that i see going viral
a lot he posted this if you can believe
that
[Music]
okay
no
what the [ __ ]
i'm so afraid of going through a
midnight mid-life crisis
i've seen so many bad ones through this
show
this is really rough can't you just let
it's like
this man
has to try to take the attention from
his daughter
like let your daughter be the star for
real
and like based on everybody other uh all
the other accounts like when tana is
talking about
they'll see but
apparently he's at every party with like
children oh my god that's a recipe for a
disaster i wonder
you got to put the kai box on your dad
it doesn't seem like he listens
at a certain point you just got to
disown him
you got to get off tick-tock that this
is going to work out look at this [ __ ]
all the comments are just brutal too
your child is literally older
oh was he dating a 19 year old he was
he was yeah we never got it was in the
dock a few weeks ago but
yeah that came out is she like disowned
him i mean
that's the worst i feel bad for her
i mean
sherry and addison have like unfollowed
him and everything if that's
at the closest you can get to disneyland
that's true that says a lot
yeah i feel bad when that's your dad you
really can't do anything about it yeah
so
here's the drama with with tana mojo
friends of the show a few days ago monty
posted a super cringe tick tock of him
growling at the camera challenging young
gravy to a boxing match yeah because on
jeff's another friend of the show
podcast last week he said
that he and addison's mom were a new
thing
but they're divorced right
america here's the video of young gravy
you feel me trying to butter the biscuit
that's her mom
i'm back in america i'm looking to make
some more peas
why they all got to be influencer what
oh and addison has also unfollowed
sherry apparently her mom oh my god
i mean yeah
so her mom is like
online doing stuff like that
well she posted remember she posted that
[ __ ] video
everyone was like no i don't know what
she posted i don't know that one either
uh when wap was a challenge she did a
whopped yes i need it bro okay give me a
second i need that mom i wasn't working
here when it happened so
this poor girl man
wow she she it's your own parents like
famous
that sucks
so anyway um
monty lopez left a message on one of tam
tana's comments on his tick tock where
she jokingly commented call the police
monty replied to her telling her to take
a bath
tana states that she already taken about
that day and monte replies to her saying
about your body count
and be honest is it over 300. [ __ ] you
are 50. why are you talking to a young
girl like this a young woman
do you think she is fat
what does it mean 300 body count is how
many people you slept with yeah oh oh i
said be honest it's more than 300.
what yeah so here's her mom by the way
so wait so okay so that's why he wanted
to find to fight young gravy was because
of that with a mom yes and he also went
on jeff's podcast and talked about it
so okay so here's her mom we're gonna
have to mute the music obviously
oh my god summer 2020 baby
oh boy
wow
my seed is all over this stop it
thanks no
no
so there's all that going on
then tana posted an expose of
screenshots and info about monty
on our tick tock here's that video
tana is
is she friends with edison
is she friends with us you see i see i
think that they like
if they're not friends they definitely
run in the same crowds but she talks
about she's like
you're acting crazy and your daughter
it's embarrassing for her yeah here it
is
you see i saw monty lopez's tick tock
and i commented i'm calling the police
and it was all fun and games actually
wouldn't say fun in games like it's
definitely the most embarrassing tick
tock i've seen of this year
i commented this and then he said go
take a bath
i did bathe today however that's beside
the point and i've held back during this
scandal you know what i mean i was
already dragged into it i said something
back in the day
but clearly
he wants
to beef
and i mean first of all why a grown man
a father
is even remotely discussing my body
count is beyond me very very obviously
seen the paparazzi videos of him
stalking me down for a selfie and i'm
getting tired of the incessant facetimes
in texts like these
and i think my young friends are very
tired of him acting like this
so
you
monty lopez was trying to rail me at the
club like fully took his shirt off
whoa dude
my dude greg paul in him would get on
famously i think
oh yeah same energy gp's up
if you want war so be it i feel kind of
strange beefing with this man at his
prehistoric age especially when i've
seen him put so many things up his nose
at several teenage events
the tea my friends
well i have no trouble uh
yeah
inside of houses
in bedrooms
because they were scared
but this makes great podcast content for
jeff and i by the way she is ruining
this man's life at an airport
for real you [ __ ] go off queen
on her way to vacation wow
this is so messed up yeah disgusting she
hit it hard she did a good job
yeah she eviscerated him poor addison
make fun of your ass looking like the
thumb from spy kids
so monty i'll take a bath
hopefully before you go to prison
but i just hope you can uh
stop and like your daughter
your wife
it's really [ __ ] embarrassing and the
fact that your narcissistic ass can't
see it is crazy so i'm gonna go bathe
and worry about my body count
but uh see you in court or jail
wow
wait he's not he really got him
that was powerful
so what we learned is basically monty
is
obsessively calling and texting tana
or her friend
both both yeah both
she had to physically pull him off a few
of her friends she says
and she's seen him doing drugs at the
teenage events teenagers wow
jesus
young gravy
called out monty this man is causing so
much trouble he's cause he's making all
these young people actually
be like what is wrong with you man here
is young gravy responding to his
challenge to box him
[Music]
i'm a grown man i'm not going to fight
you over tick-tock drama
you got one of the most successful
daughters in the world and
you decide to act half her age to try to
get some attention while embarrassing
your whole family so
grow up
get some help and if we cross paths in
real life don't do anything stupid
[Music]
true that was pretty [ __ ] epic too
another good one i kind of like what he
said if we pop if we cross paths yeah
don't do anything stupid i like that
yeah
like i don't want to fight you dumb
[ __ ] weirdo dude right
um
this is so bad
sending i had no idea
like i've seen his name come up i didn't
know it was this bad yeah
monty lopez ladies and gentlemen
maybe he'll want to fight me after this
huh
yeah
monty i'm challenging you
you little
troll like gremlin he's built like a
troll doll actually
oh
he is built like a troll doll
you see him shirtless we do a little
trolling
look at this his i don't know why i
thought we were not making fun of
people's uh
inherent attributes what am i making fun
of what's wrong with the troll doll
it kind of looks like a troll doll too
isn't it in the face
what did i say just stating a
fact
an observation
a fact
all right i don't know what else to say
y'all it's the weekend baby [ __ ] yeah
thank you to happy shame
probably i think that's gotta be our
saudi benefactor
indeed web 2.9
not quite at three
but almost to our sub count
well
have a good good weekend everybody
you know
you're gonna play uh some fortnite you
don't know that
uh no we're actually go we have plans
this weekend oh you got like family in
town don't you yeah yeah
as much as i would love to play fortnite
with you
as ninja
poor ninja bye ninja
with a gift think of it
i will be busy this weekend
but i hope you guys have fun
we haven't played since that first day
that they all begged me
to play with them and they all
disappeared let's play tonight then
where you been let's play i've been
around
you've been around i am on every day bro
it's everyday bro every day bro with
that ninja flow it's fortnite chicken
dinner never seen before
chicken
chicken chicken they're opening uh kfc
in my city
yeah i heard that's big news for you big
news dude congratulations
thank you guys
what's fortnite
is that a video game
okay well console
really what are you doing it
uh it's actually one of the most
beautiful pieces of art that i've ever
seen
uh fortnite really the arts dope yeah
when i
saw darth vader uh doing the floss on
top of the dead body of boba fett
uh i had never seen anything quite that
beautiful
yeah so what's so dope about the art did
they like draw it by hand
oh well you see
well
yes yes crazy have you guys heard of
elden ring
crazy
this is like a shooter
[Laughter]
what like how do you play it
is it not a shooter
oh it's like is it like a soccer game
like nba 2k
whoa
yeah i like video games too bro
sometimes i play 2k with my homies
do you play 2k ever heard of gta
whoa
that's crazy
wow you want candy crush bro
all
too much fun
ladies and gentlemen thank you for the
gifted thank you
thank you for watching thank you for the
gifted thank you for watching today
gifted
we will be back uh of course next week
with a whole new week of content it
never stops
it never ends
you will never get rid of us we will be
here forever
four days a week maybe five someday in
the future we don't know
they don't want you to be here they
don't want me to be here but i am
i show up every [ __ ] day
except tuesday
and saturday and sunday
all right y'all tata
have a great weekend lots of love thanks
for watching
bye bye
[Music]
[Music]
don't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
says
[Music]
[Music]
on my face
[Music]